RFK Jr is currently polling very very
well as the main rival to Joe Biden on
the Democratic primary ticket we'll see
how that plays out he's also polling
more favorably in some areas than Donald
Trump
he is told Joe Rogan on The Joe Rogan
Experience that he is concerned the CIA
could assassinate him he has to take
these things seriously because of what
happened to his uncle it's a it's a
remarkable conversation that I really
want to dive into considering how well
he's doing the polls how people really
like this guy and the fact that we're
now at the point in U.S history where
everyone's basically like yeah JFK was
killed by our own government we'll get
into that and then we have our own
current President Joe Biden who uh
claimed that people pull up in trucks
and cities and start selling guns in the
street and it's just a nonsensical story
but more importantly he wrapped up by
saying God Save the Queen
and where was it Connecticut I believe
so in Connecticut amazing well okay I
guess so uh take your pick Democrats I
guess we're gonna get into that but
before we do my friends head over to
Preferred
itsolutions.com preferred IT solutions
this is not a paid sponsor spot these
are Tim cast members that we are
highlighting and promoting as we are
going to start doing this for our Friday
shows you guys are what make all this
possible
preferred I.T Solutions is a Christian
business that provides 100 secure
encrypted telecommunications and I.T
Services Nationwide no matter if your
business is in a city or in the middle
of nowhere we can secure and protect
your organization we work with any sized
business whether small or large some of
our clients include call center
celebrities Health Facilities schools
manufacturing churches and many more our
team is passionate about providing
security and bleeding edge technology at
an affordable rate the link is in the
description below shout out to Tim cast
members who help make all of this
possible and we're going to shout you
out the goal is every Friday to just
pick one of the one of the uh members
you guys submit your projects and things
you're working on and we will shout you
out so again preferred IT solutions you
make all this possible were
eternally grateful and we're happy to
shout you out you guys need to support
businesses that that don't hate you that
actually share your values and preferred
I.T solutions they are good people also
don't forget go to timcast.com click
join us become a member support our work
directly and you can also click the
mobile app button and download the
timcast Android mobile app they will
soon be available for iPhone and Android
in the play stores and the in the App
Stores but while we await approval and
review you can download the Android
installation package directly from our
website smash that like button subscribe
to this channel joining us tonight to
talk about all this and more ladies and
gentlemen we got Elon
yes sir Elan Elon srilovich thank you
for having me on Moscow sorry everybody
almost almost Elon Musk minus the 150
billion dollars ah yes yes so who are
you what do you do uh so I'm the CEO of
eggard watch company uh we're known for
putting out some pretty controversial
ads in support of a lot of the things
that you talk about and uh absolutely
and yeah so that's that's one of the
things that I'm also an actor uh by the
way all our films for my company are
available on our website at
guardwatches.com we have an hour films
section it's worth checking them out and
uh actor different shows I was on The
Walking Dead
Netflix's slasher which is a crazy show
uh Deepwater Horizon just a bunch of
different shows yeah you got a lot of
attention when you put out a commercial
supporting women's sports yes most
recently we put out an ad called erased
where we it's kind of like a unique
build up it's this girl who's who's
trying her whole life to become a track
runner and she's inspired by her father
and she's the best she's really the best
she says is no woman that can beat us
and then in the final moment she
realizes she's competing against a
biological male and she has no chance in
it then it kind of highlights in sports
where this has happened before most
egregiously with uh Fallon Fox and MMA
very serious that was like 10 years ago
wasn't it yeah yeah breaking the skull
of uh yeah Angela Hill I believe I can't
remember which fighter but so uh we'll
get in all that thanks for hanging out
to be a blast we got Hannah Claire
bremelo hi I'm Hannah Claire brimlow I'm
a writer for timcast.com I'm happy to be
back
yes and hello guys my name is Brett
dasovich I'm the host of Pop Culture
crisis Monday through Friday 3 P.M
Eastern Standard Time right here on
YouTube glad to be here and uh my name
is Kellen filling in for surge as usual
on Fridays I hope we can dive into your
Walking Dead stuff that's really cool I
had no idea that's really cool I want to
ask about slasher Brandon J McLaren
slasher no it's uh what was the uh
director's name no he's a actor in it oh
it's possible because it's Anthology so
each season has its own run okay I was
the one of the main actors on season
three okay uh I don't know about the
other season but yeah if you find out
like it's it's got a pretty tight cast
you want to pull the mic up a little bit
oh sorry about that yeah no problem
let's uh uh we're all good then right
we'll jump into this yeah let's do it
here's a story from the post millennial
RFK Jr tells Joe Rogan he is concerned
the CIA might assassinate him you know
this is crazy they say during the
interview with Joe Rogan Kennedy said
his uncle John F Kennedy quote was at
war with his military and intelligence
apparatus after he said he wanted to
take the CIA and shatter it into a
thousand pieces and also scatter into
the wind
he uh who he said had lied to get him to
invade Cuba Kennedy discussed his
uncle's refusal to send soldiers into
Vietnam at the military-industrial
complex's request he noted that JFK was
killed a month after ordering all troops
out of Vietnam when he determined that
75 Americans who were killed in the
country were too many quote
he believed that the view of Americans
abroad should not be you know a soldier
with a gun it should be a Peace Corps
volunteer building you know Wells
Kennedy said it should be usaid helping
poor people and it should be the
alliance for Progress building middle
class and that's what he did and he
started the Kennedy milk program do you
know give nutrition to the poor kids all
over the world as a result of that in
Africa today there's more statues to
John Kennedy more boulevards named after
uh named after more Hospital schools
universities Avenues and all the major
cities named after him than any other
president the podcast host asked him
what do you think happens when you get
an office like if you're talking about
your uncle who was assassinated and you
believe the intelligence agencies were
part of that what happens to you and he
replies I gotta be careful and I'm aware
of that and I you know I'm aware of that
of that danger Kennedy responded I don't
live in fear of it you know at all but
I'm not stupid about it and I take
precautions
did you think
at any point in your lives we get to the
point where we would be sitting on a
show like this and be like two very
prominent individuals one who's pulling
highly for the next presidential
election would outright say that the
intelligence agencies killed a sitting
President also his uncle
you know like uh 10 years ago I would
have said this is an impossibility and
the sad reality is that right now I'm
sitting here and it's almost like
there's no no response to it whatsoever
it's almost become unexpected kind of
thing where the most extreme possible
thing plays out I know people who were
completely shocked he even entered the
race for this reason they're like
there's no way there's too much of a
Target on him uh which I also find to be
kind of interesting like he says he's
interested in it he he's aware of it
he's gonna uh he he's not gonna live in
fear but he is aware that coming out
with these accusations and then seeking
the presidency is uh maybe not in his
best in his in his personal interest
yeah it definitely puts us was it wasn't
there movement on the Warren Commission
like 10 years ago too there was like a
an unveiling of documents around this
time 10 years ago or something they keep
doing stuff like that like every so
often remember we were talking about
last time like every time Joe Biden
screws something up you just release a
couple of documents let's step out it'll
be great also you should worry too
because there's a lot of streets named
after Martin Luther King and a lot of
people believe that the government had a
hand in that as well yep a lot of people
I don't think they do it so much anymore
I'm actually not super worried about RFK
Jr getting assassinated I mean I think
it's a possibility I think uh the powers
that be have it within them
it might be something like uh you're
going for a burger and you get mugged
yeah oh too bad but typically I think
they go with character assassination
because I want to make sure your message
can't persist well it's far more
effective I mean if you want to take
someone out nowadays you take them out
by just erasing the person they are just
creating an entire villain around them
and they're more effective at that I
mean you don't want to have a martyr
yeah I mean remember that the mainstream
media will not acknowledge that he's a
serious Contender for the Democratic
nomination they refer to him
consistently as a fringe candidate and
then they immediately bring up his
theoretical stance as an anti-vaxxer
right like they use that to to tear him
down as much as possible in doing so
they don't realize that he has broad
appeal they will not acknowledge that he
actually has an interesting shot he
plays an interesting role in politics
right now because I think they are
afraid of him the best thing for uh
America's left to do right now is try to
get him to stop talking as fast as
possible you know what's super
interesting about the vaccine thing is
they don't realize how many people in
their own party are actually on board
with his message well his his polling is
I think he's rivaling is he is he I
think he's beating Joe Biden in
favorability that is I think the things
that he's saying are lighting up regular
people who don't like Joe Biden don't
like what the Democratic party's become
and they don't like Donald Trump Yep
they're they're I think there are a lot
of people who voted for Trump
I'm sorry voted voted for Biden against
Trump I think you know that was why I
really believe no one voted for Biden
they voted against Trump exactly and now
that RFK comes along they're like don't
know don't care he's a Kennedy sure fund
whatever you uh yougov says that RFK has
higher favorability than any other
presidential candidate running in 2024.
49 it is true that there is almost no
appeal for Joe Biden because I like like
we cover pop culture and I've seen
several celebrities who are just like
James Van Der Beek was like we have to
at least have the discussion that other
candidates are a possibility uh um Arnie
uh the governator recently was saying
that he wishes he could run uh given
that he's not a naturalized American he
wasn't born in America because he says
that there's there's nobody right now
that can unite everyone which is tacitly
admitting that they're not uniting
anyone right now and these are
mainstream celebrities who would
normally fall in line for leftist or
democrat policies I don't think uniting
everyone's a realistic goal right yeah
it's not everyone to compromise I mean
this guy became the governor as a
republican in California so anything's
possible that used to be a thing though
I mean there used to be a Democrat yeah
there used to be a republican stronger
originally in Orange County right like
that was a different time we are so used
to seeing uh America through a modern
lens that we forget I mean we're in West
Virginia West Virginia used to vote
consistently Democratic the parties
shift the same way that the party shift
in ideology and they have Drifters left
the voters shift too to stick with their
core beliefs
yeah I believe at this point that kind
of unity is just impossible and I don't
think anyone deep down believes it what
if
we get this magical unicorn scenario
RFK runs in the primary
Biden wins
RFK says I'm not leaving
Trump wins and then Trump says RFK Jr
run with me let's let's let's unite what
we're working on together for the
American people what happens if it comes
Trump RFK Jr single ticket a trump
Kennedy ticket that is a powerful I mean
I've seen a lot of uh uh speculation
that Hill RFK Jr will run as a third
party which will basically have a Ross
Perot effect and Hemorrhage uh voters
away from Joe Biden I mean RFK is a a
real problem for the Democrats and you
know he just has to be not enough of a
threat to the Republicans to Hemorrhage
moderate voters who lean in both
directions yeah if he runs as an
independent he's definitely going to
cause a Major Impact for the Democratic
party it's it's he's gonna
unintentionally or intentionally
sabotage them completely yeah I think
residential debates are somewhat useless
right like we do get some fun sound
bites when Donald Trump's on stage but
they don't really tell us anything uh
but I would love to see Kennedy debate
Trump or Biden or literally anyone
because I think he is sort of this this
breath of fresh air I think there are
you know not enough people who are in
his position because the Democratic
party has drifted so far to the left
they only field extremist candidates
yeah and he's one of those people who
will say whatever he truly believes
which is very dangerous for them I mean
they really do need like you said people
to fall in line he's not that he's a
kind you know the Tulsi gabbard remember
what happened with her like the second
you start speaking your mind you're a
threat to them even if you're in their
party I had a story where I was like
after the debates and I was talking
about during the day you know during the
primaries during the election and I was
like talking to a friend of mine who
just really really hates Donald Trump
really hates Donald Trump and I was like
oh yeah I really like the stuff that
Tulsi gabbard was saying is like Donald
Trump is an existential threat to
America I'm like that what that has
nothing to do with what the hell we're
talking about right now because they'd
already cast her off as somebody who is
a fringe candidate with these crazy
beliefs and he just kind of lumps all
those people in together whether
Democrat Republican if they don't fall
in line for what at that time would have
been you know your uh your standard
Democrat policies which have gone even
further left since then
um it's crazy
yeah I always I always talk about how
there's new normals created all the time
and so you look every every two to three
years now it used to be the concept of
like a new normal would probably take
decades for them to happen and now you
look on key issues that people used to
vote on they're just becoming more
extreme about those issues to the point
where we're so polarized that there's no
form of rationale anymore in it where
like if I would have told you you know
five ten years ago we're going to put
biological males in prison with women
who have a history of sexually
assaulting women you would say the
entire country would be out protesting
on the street I gotta ask are you do you
face any kind of backlash career-wise
for bringing these subjects up
absolutely well I mean what's that been
like some of them some of them I don't
even know if I should talk about uh from
a legal perspective I will say this we
used to have a lot of celebrities who
supported our our brand uh especially
after this last erased ad that we did
the one with the transgender athlete uh
beating the woman uh we got a lot of
complaints from people saying you're a
transphobic company you're spreading
hate speech to the celebrities who wear
your watches know that you believe these
things and then all of a sudden I
started getting some emails from people
that represent these celebrities wow
threatening do you answer back I'm a
pro-woman company like I I think women
are great and they should compete in
sports you know like the so the to the
people who send the emails I actually
invite them on uh our company podcast to
talk to us and they never accept they
just tell me to go kill myself wow to
the to the legal aspect of things I do
my best to avoid a lawsuit because like
the Womanhood bracelet that we were
selling uh we're going to donate a
percentage of that to Charities that
support the things that we believe in it
becomes very hard if I'm having to fight
legal battles and that's kind of how
they win they try and destroy you in
that way so I'm just sticking to my guns
I play nice where I have to play nice
and when I believe that it's time to
fight back I do but I want to fight back
with a cultural change and I do that
through these videos because we had I'll
be honest with you during this last
video we put out I got a lot of people
who are who even have trans kids saying
the current message for the lgbtq
community is hurting my child people are
starting to hate my child because it's
coming becoming too extreme yeah well we
had a you know front of the show Dale
turn around the other day talking about
you know he's a gay married man and he
was saying the activists are making it
hard and embarrassing for him he was
saying that his husband said you know it
used to be 10 years ago you just mind
your own business and people leave you
alone but now what's going on they're
actually embarrassed to mention that
they're they're getting married
that's that that's what the activists
have made they've pushed it to the
extreme it's like a weird shift where
all they were fighting for originally it
was the right to live their lives the
way they wanted and now the movements
become so extreme that it's forcing
everyone else to kind of celebrate and
be involved and accept everything to the
point where it's damaging them and it's
damaging the way they want it to live
their lives and I don't know how many of
them are aware of just how much damage
it's caused because I used to be in full
transparency a person who would go uh
walk for uh the pride parade you know I
just believed in the notion of anyone
who wants to be married should be able
to be married and over the years because
of how extreme it's going I'm like I
won't support a group that is twerking
in front of kids in you know thongs it
just started to gross me out I'm like
this is not appropriate and then I'm
culture transphobic or homophobic for
that or the other one that they get the
one that I've gotten a lot because I've
been talking to a lot of my friends
lately I've kind of reestablished
contact with friends that just I haven't
talked to in a long time and the number
one sentiment that they have when you
tell them these stories and you show
them these things are going on is that
it's not as big of a deal as you're
making it out to be that it's not really
like maybe it's happening but it's
happening once in a while but that's
because they are pre they're not privy
to the information because the media
doesn't report on it that way the media
focuses on what they want to focus on
which is going to be anything but that
so when you bring it up you're like look
I don't want you know I'm we're from the
generation I'm I'm 36 so right in the
heart of when gay marriage is legalized
a lot of our generation was like yes
it's absolutely a right for these people
like I don't I don't care what you do in
the bedroom I've never cared and I'd
imagine that a lot of people our age
especially if you're someone like me who
grew up in a liberal area like you you
just you didn't care right and now you
see it and you're just first of all
you're not allowed to not care you're
forced to care about all of these things
and a lot of it is just that how far do
you push it before you say that's not
what this is about anymore this is
clearly grown to be something James
Lindsay talks about this a lot about how
it's morphed and it's a lot of it is
it's Marxism and it's a lot of other
political influences that have latched
on to causes that preyed upon your
desire to be a decent person you're
desire to be accepting and they're very
nefarious and they're doing it on
purpose okay I think there's something
so interesting about the idea of the
things that are under attack have to do
with absolute truth or objective reality
and that those are the first things to
come under attack is you're talking
about Marxism the first thing they have
to do is destroy your belief in
something greater than yourself if you
have a belief in God and they did that a
long time ago Hollywood in these
industries long since decoupled people
from the concept of religion in this
country it's the fundamental binary that
now exists that is at War and when
people say there's a spiritual battle
I'm someone who grew up without any true
form of connection to religion and in
recent years because of everything I see
I realize it's the glue that will hold
things together because I have to have a
reason why I believe in some kind of
absolute ethic why the denial of basic
realities is wrong because if I don't
have that I have nothing and I realize
that that ideology has permeated so
strongly on the left that the only road
that you are left with is nihilism which
is why these people people are seeking
such identity in this they're gripping
onto this as their their mode to Value
yeah you can get complete validation
from it I mean that's the saddest part
of all of it it's very broken people
looking to uh gain Authority and gain
sympathy and gain value through other
people's approval and uh being able to
show that they're compliant to this
ideology right I mean that is the
biggest thing I think religion provides
a lot of people of course there are
institutions that are you know not great
but generally if you have a common sense
of morality and structure you're not
seeking the approval of everyone around
you because you have higher value than
that and I think that takes it away from
being about yourself because right now I
feel like we've cultivated this
incredibly self-centered uh generation
right we talk about rampant narcissism
especially in social media we see people
are constantly looking for validation
and they want you to be talking about
themselves they are thinking about
themselves more than anything else and
when we had stronger communities through
religion we thought about other people
we thought about how we could contribute
to that and I think that's so powerful I
think that we don't have enough of that
and I am sad for the people that grew up
thinking I have to be constantly
thinking about my own identity above all
else because that's a very Hollow
existence you have you can't identify
with a character in a movie unless that
character looks exactly like you now you
have to be there you have to literally
be that character otherwise how would
you possibly relate to their story no
it's well that's that's the funny thing
is they're simultaneously saying
this actor can't portray this character
because they're not the character and
then at the same time being like but
this this character is completely
different can it's it's seemingly
arbitrary and this is what I think shows
leftist ideology is typically about just
gaining power and destroying systems
always that'll be in Scarlett Johansson
can't play a trans character because
you're not trans but a black woman can
play uh Marie Antoinette or who did they
play uh she played Angeline and Berlin
there you go uh can play Anne Boleyn
because who cares anyway and it's like
some identities are okay to destroy
but my attitude would be like pick one
and stick with it I don't if you say
that nobody can do it then okay fine if
you say everyone can do it then okay
fine but you can't have both hierarchy
the entire point is that it's
hypocritical the entire point is that
they can hold up four fingers until you
use C5 they have to destroy your ability
to to think freely and by the way the
whole notion that you can't play a
transfer okay so I was on a TV show I
played a bisexual guy on the show uh
like uh on that show slasher and
interestingly enough one of my castmates
released an article after the show
saying people who aren't lgbtq should
not play
uh characters who are lgbtq did this
cast member talk to you about this
before they really started this cast
member did not acknowledge me much on on
set to be honest uh and so it was very
interesting but my response to that was
number one how do you know what I am now
you're putting me in a position to
announce if I'm closeted if I don't if I
have parents who wouldn't accept that
now I have to announce to the world to
be accepted in your view that I am lgbtq
so that is no longer a personal
preference you're now forcing me to come
out with it another thing you're doing
is how are casting directors gonna put
what do you want them to do you want
them to ask you if you're gay now you
know they ask me my ethnicity now I'm
half Iraqi so anytime I'm asked my
ethnicity I say I'm Iraqi the um the I
like right now the casting directors
have more power in Hollywood than just
about any other like outside of your HR
departments like that is the most
important department to most of the
people in that industry and what's funny
is you mentioned uh playing a role that
was bisexual I think when I was looking
at the of data 24 of Hollywood of people
who work in Hollywood identify as
lgbtqia plus so they're already highly
over represented amongst their
population you know within the industry
uh and they have rules that go into
effect about you know demographics that
have to be hired in certain departments
in these things and it's all and it's
all identity based because they're
obsessed with it because it is a
narcissistic culture that is extremely
self-hating the funniest thing you
mentioned about that earlier is have you
ever noticed it even comes in with
climate with climate activists there's a
lot of really really bad nihilism there
because they're like the world's coming
to an end why do we care anyways that's
the worst type of propaganda that I see
it's the stuff that's saying like one
thing that I see a lot of now and it's
honestly scary to see as many posts
about is people say I didn't ask to be
born
I get so annoyed but again you know what
that comes from that comes from the
denial of the notion that you are
special by nature of existing that you
you take that away from people they can
get to that place where it's like
there's this level of entitlement where
I didn't even ask to be here so I can do
whatever I want I don't know anyone
anything and if there's no faith in a
higher power then what the hell do you
do yeah like there's nothing to latch on
to and I've I'll be honest with you I've
been there I've been a very nihilistic
person I've suffered with depression my
whole life I think one of the Saving
Grace Graces a person can have is
finding uh spiritual aspects to live by
and just understanding that they are
again just by nature of existing by
nature of being a human being that you
have value and if you can connect to
that it can save your life it's a very
powerful thing
purpose purpose and this is why it's one
of the components of lokeness not the
absolute but for a lot of people they're
desperate they don't know why they're
here and so give them a reason and
they'll latch onto it in desperation no
connection to their families this is the
idea of community right they're saying
you should be nice to our community and
we're welcoming you to our community and
chosen family and this that and the
other they're saying we're giving you
something to be a part of because you
feel so adrift out there like that's
creepy that's disgusting especially
because most of these people have
families right yes it's the denial of
the things that you have to join this
effective cult and there's about 30
years of Hollywood or more pushing the
idea of chosen family over your actual
family because they I used to believe on
my good days when I was less cynical I
would say it was just interesting
storytelling meaning that it's very
interesting for Disney to tell you a
story where one parent has been deceased
because it makes for interesting
characters right but the more you learn
about Hollywood the more you learn about
how bad these industries are you have to
wonder if it's not at least in some way
shape or form social engineering that
has evolved over times so I I mean I am
certain at this I used to believe that
kind of the happenstance of moral
relativism
was just this kind of unfortunate result
that the second you have any amount of
moral relativism you have an absolute
denial of objective truth or absolute
truth that there's some kind of higher
ethical standard but now I believe it's
truly Insidious and it is social
engineering and I know this because we
can prove it we can look at this Oscar
winner who just came out and said I have
three kids one of them is is trans one
of them is non-binary and the other
one's gay that is statistically
impossible you can go play the lottery
that's your chances of having three kids
in a row that are all non-binary unless
you socially engineer it Megan Fox
Angelina Jolie Charlize Theron it's the
women I'm telling well you know
but hold on I will I will say this yes
most likely uh you know I think it was
Bill Maher who asked
why is it that in Ohio we don't see this
but in California we do it's uh it's
something we must be doing and I think
we shouldn't uh downplay uh Plastics and
endocrine disruptors I think we should
absolutely focus on that shout out to
Alex Jones who has that famous clip
where he had to turn in the frogs gay
RFK Jr actually has a similar clip where
he mentions that when you put atrazine
in the water with frogs the frogs begin
to uh yes change yeah so the thing with
atrazine though from what I understood
about it is it actually causes
physiological changes like higher rates
of micropenis uh yeah and all types of
stuff like that are we seeing that in
the human population well I'm just
saying I think I think we should not
ignore that perhaps in California you
have these people who it it I think it's
very likely to be social
um very likely but I do think there's a
strong possibility that over the past
couple of decades you've had women
ingesting all of their food wrapped in
plastic we all have been but you know
women are eating everything and this is
this is relatively new in the past
couple of generations go to an antique
shop and everything I it's crazy I went
to an antique store and they had like
orange knee-high or something metal can
yeah that's nuts thick metal can to
drink a soda and now you have women who
are ingesting all this plastic while
they're pregnant the plastic goes into
the womb and it negatively impacts the
child I'm wondering if
we could be looking at something on an
asbestos a DDT level scale where it's
praised and championed and used
everywhere and everything and then
caused massive negative uh there's a
massive a massive negative outcome and
now we know we've seen all these stories
in the news about how Plastics leech
phthalates pcbs Etc and their endocrine
disruptors
do do we just ignore that we have these
stories saying this thing is happening
and then we just
don't acknowledge I mean like we need to
get off that absolutely there's
absolutely a connection between Health
across the board and Development Across
the board and what we're eating I mean I
the rate of people with autoimmune
diseases I have two autoimmune diseases
three technically and this is unheard of
historically
um and they it you're seeing rates of
Lupus which was historically an
extremely rare rare rare autoimmune
disease the point where it was a joke on
like house house
you keep your drugs in a lupus textbook
but now now you are seeing legitimately
lupus pop up in many places
um I mean Selena Gomez has it doesn't
you yes yes she does and it's crazy
she's young and since they're bringing
house back they should actually
incorporate that into the storyline well
there there's uh an article in giant
robot ungiant freaking robot about how
they wanna that Hulu is going to be
bringing it back for a limited run I
don't know if that's possible I don't
know if you can tell those jokes now
um it's gonna be a whole other country I
invite everyone to go re-watch it with
modern
talking to someone who identifies
seriously a different gender well watch
no watch the episode where he has the 16
year old the hermaphrodite I have seen
that yes
um that that is an incredible episode
but
a lot of stuff like I am always
um
I always point out to all my friends
like you should consider getting off
birth control right because birth
control is designed to disrupt women's
hormones so that's also true of plastic
that's true of a lot of things that we
celebrate we get excited about but we
ultimately find out later maybe we
shouldn't have as much of this uh we are
society that when we have an innovation
we tend to be like it's great use it
everywhere and then later decades later
we're like oh perhaps not but there are
some things we're not allowed to
question so again for me the big one
that I always say to women is birth
control you should question birth
control I know for some people it's a
good thing and it can be helpful but
generally long-term birth control use is
uh there's a study that's out right now
which got published by Cambridge
University press uh women who start
birth control under the age of 20. so as
teenagers have are 130 more likely to
develop depression than women who do not
and then all women who start birth
control have uh higher rates of
depression than women who do not what do
we hear about people all the time I'm
lonely I'm depressed I'm having trouble
connecting with people well maybe we
should question what we're putting into
our Bart at bodies and I'm happy for
that to be food I'm happy for that to be
environmental but again I think we have
to talk about the biggest change to
women's life which is that uh 65 of
women in America are on some form of
birth of birth control typically oral
contraceptive and you couple that with
social media and how depressing again
people are becoming because of social
media and it's a perfect storm it might
not just be a singular aspect it might
be a bunch of factors coming into play
at once I mean for sure what you eat for
sure what you drink for sure what you
see on TV for sure what you absorb
through your phone what you're shown in
you know your interactions on the
streets yeah they have a long-term
effect on you each one is happening now
in conjunction which is probably why
we're seeing the escalation of things so
quickly because it's not a singular
factor which in itself might have taken
decades right we're seeing tons of
things together hit you and that's why
you know you might be seeing the changes
you're talking about that might have
taken 50 years of of long-term
addressing exposure happening over 10
years because there's this social
engineering aspect there's we also know
that uh I read this study I think we
talked about on the show there is a
birth control that women had taken and
they could still get pregnant while on
it and if they did they had a
masculinized female baby that I think
they said every one of them turned out
to be lesbians so I I think this stuff
is deeply altering our physiology but
it's not just the Plastics or whatever
I mean the chemicals in our food in
general words you can't even pronounce
so we try we do a lot here to get away
from that stuff we have those epic meat
bars those protein bars yeah the
ingredient is like pork salt pepper
amazing beef salt pepper Venison and uh
you know we have this here we have these
uh glass bottles that we put filtered
water in re mineralized but I think it's
also a big Pharma
these drugs so I have experience with
Bigfoot I have Crohn's disease I also
have a genetic defect which causes my
cholesterol to be like ridiculously high
and oddly enough I just did a heart scan
and I don't have evidence of
artherosclerosis which contradicts all
the knowledge we know about high
cholesterol and so there's a big shift
happening in medicine a lot of my
doctors are like hey let's maybe pull
you off not give you tons of biologics
I've luckily have good doctors and
they're like let's try the AIP diet the
you know anti-inflammatory diet get you
on clean meats that are not processed in
any way shape or form keep you away from
certain vegetables that are you know
you're not able to tolerate right now
don't eat anything processed don't eat
refined sugar keeping me on a strict
diet and I'm seeing way better results
than that but I got on a medication
called repatha uh and I'm not going to
bash this medication it lowered my
cholesterol tremendously but I ended up
and like this is incredibly rare and it
shouldn't happen on this medication at
all in the hospital with rhabdo rhabdo
is what you see like CrossFit athletes
get when they're dehydrated and
overworked your muscle is dying and it
leaks into your body and it can kill you
it can clog your kidneys and uh and so
they denied that there's any correlation
between their medication developing
rhabdo
I've been a competitive athlete my whole
life from for fighting uh I have never
developed this I didn't even do a hard
workout this time about it two days
after the injection can I say it's from
that no I would never say it's
absolutely from that but again there's
we don't know what we're putting into
our body half the time and the
pharmaceutical companies are not out for
our best interests and they benefit it
we're talking about a potential increase
in autoimmune disease and autoimmune
zenous chronic who benefits from when
you're chronically sick big Pharma they
need you as customers forever there it's
it's hard to say because I don't want to
assume the worst in everyone but if
you're in the pharmaceutical industry
curing patience is actually not in your
best interest chronic illness is a
godsend for a big Pharma chronic illness
is the best it beats everything else
because you have it for your whole life
and a lot of them don't necessarily
lower your lifespan that much they just
make it very very difficult to live with
it do you think that um maybe some of
the things you're experiencing are
caused by the Pharmaceuticals or by one
million diet all right one million
percent diet one million percent died in
my life has affected me I think there's
environmental factors that have affected
me I think people don't realize the
effects of I've traveled a lot of my
life and I've lived in like different
places I've lived in places with mold
for sure black mold other things like
that and uh I'm sure that's had an
effect uh certain stressors in life can
cause an effect again if you're I think
like I said earlier I've suffered from
depression and just states of nihilism I
didn't believe in something bigger than
myself I'm sure that living in a
negative state had an impact on my
health as well a lot of people don't
acknowledge the effects that stress
depression all these things have on your
health
the mind-body connection was largely
ignored by doctors until very recently
where they said no the mind really does
have an impact on your body we do have
to take these things more seriously
long-term anxiety does increase your
risk of certain complications in life
like heart disease and things like that
so
um I think that luckily there's a shift
happening for good doctors but I also
saw during the the whole vaccine thing
how many crazy doctors marching with uh
with all the protesters you know during
the BLM really well I think we brings up
yesterday that the it was a Colorado Sun
there are other outlets that said the
BLM protest actually reduced the spread
of code yes of course you had a video
out of New York where the doctors are
standing outside waving and cheering for
all the people Marching In the Street
there were doctors saying like this is a
worthy cause so it's worth doing you're
saying I can't go to work but this can
happen but then when people were like it
may be a worthy cause but you're causing
us harm they went actually it looks like
these are reducing the spread of coven
this is the scariest thing in the world
to me that people can accept
such ludicrous positions I remember when
this happened I remember I spoke to my
dad when the the doctors were out
protesting with the BLM writers and my
dad said look the truth is people see
the numbers will go up and they'll
acknowledge that these people are wrong
it won't matter because they won't
report the numbers going up and it won't
matter
they'll give it another reason it's it's
it was a trump uh rally that super
spread it you know what you said earlier
that actually made me
that makes me a little bit upset you
said these people are just omitted
certain information and I agree they are
but on us on another level when I talk
to people that I've known for years and
I tell them hey this is what's going on
at a at some of these drag shows that
you think kids should go to here's
pictures and video they go it doesn't
matter that's not most of them that's
just that one they will rationalize
anything at this point it's not a matter
of lacking information it's a matter of
your entire identity being wrapped
around this singular ideology and that
if anyone challenges it you will always
find a way to rationalize why they are
wrong and it's okay another one remember
when um Trump left office in the in the
death counters magically went away on
all the the new sets it's just evil it's
just evil the death counters that were
never accurate I mean there were all
sorts of like very subtly slipped out
corrections after the fact I remember uh
some city in Massachusetts was like oh
we have to reduce our number by like
several thousand and one of the examples
was someone died while they had covered
but in a car accident yeah and so it was
sort of like I see so you're patting
your numbers here team like it didn't
make any sense there was Financial
benefits to that too
they would present this this information
they always there's always an appeal to
Authority look at our data and look at
these statistics but all of it is
misrepresented and wrong and so you can
never create a culture that fully at
least for a lot of people there you grow
an intense amount of skepticism they can
never trust any of these institutions
which personally I feel like is good you
should question these things on the
other hand will we need reliable
information to make informed decisions
it's not out there yeah you have two
options now you're either misinformed or
uninformed yeah and that's a scary place
to be especially with things that
involve your safety and health and we've
done something that's so dangerous just
on another deep kind of social level
which is we've taken the historical
virtues that have made societies great
like courage strength being able to
stand up in the face of adversity and
we've altered them completely and put
things like
security you know don't be scared
agreeableness those are now our highest
virtues those are the antithesis of
Virtues they're not just the denial of
the other virtues they are the opposite
of them and so I mean that's just a
whole other problem in itself is that
what part of a society becoming more
feminized agreeableness being women
being committed higher on the agreeable
scale in all of those other things that
you're talking about whether we're
talking about courage have some aspect
of conflict behind it a lot of the time
right have being willing to stand up for
yourself being willing to say no I'm not
going to accept this garbage story
you're telling me uh I I just wonder if
that plays at least some role in it in
the fact that a lot of it now is uh
appeal to Authority right like you don't
want to be the conspiracy theorist right
I was told that it's bad to do your own
research I was told that uh by a very
reliable source at this mainstream
Network that doing your own research is
a sign of white supremacy or something I
don't know you know but they were saying
that right they were saying you should
like now is the time there was articles
in like Salon that were saying now is
the time to not do your own research
yeah don't critically think the New York
Times it's bad well you know what's the
historical uh standard for when a
society is about to collapse in their
statues and all that stuff if they
become more feminized statues are coming
down uh credit crunch widespread
military conflict it really does feel a
lot like Rome but we could only read
about Rome we didn't experience it so
you don't know we've got Wi-Fi are we in
an agency
debauchery how do you say that word
debauchery yeah I mean well we're in
some deadly sins are are well pronounced
and they're virtual it's virtuous now to
to go and be prideful in all of these
things and it really does feel like our
society is doing that like well falling
apart but speaking of that I I gotta
pull up the story I have to pull up the
story we have this tweet from England
Brewery I have to because we talked
about the Music Cafe presented by
Yingling having an all-ages drag show
loud babies and we're big fans of
Yingling and so we were concerned we
were like Say It Ain't So you're not
sponsoring a drag show that allows
babies well Yingling has responded they
said
Yingling has been a supporter of Art's
quest for many years along with over 300
local community supporters we're proud
to be part of their efforts to
revitalize an industrial neighborhood in
Bethlehem PA through our Arts Quest
sponsorship we have naming rights to the
Music Fest Cafe presented by Yingling
venue Arts Quest independently plans the
events and policies that take place at
this venue and all of their other
performance areas Yingling actively
promotes responsible drinking for
patrons 21 years of age and older we are
working to align with artsquest
regarding appropriate age restrictions
for venues associated with our
sponsorship we support their decision to
restrict attendance to 18 plus for the
June 30th show for more information
contact info artsquest.org that my
friends is how you handle it this I
haven't I do not care about a drag show
at all I am concerned that they that the
slippery slope it persists as such that
we got to the point where they're like
let's have a you know gay burlesque
shows but allow children and babies and
even if Yingling didn't know the amount
was happening they put their name on
this so Yingling what do they do I would
I would make this assumption this is
what it seems to me it seems like
Yingling seeing the response reached out
to them and said guys it's got to be
adults only and got them to do it and
that is exactly what should have
happened I'm I'm remarkable as I'm
massively impressed I'm gonna go buy
more Yingling this was fantastic just to
keep it for adults we absolutely
such a common sense thing yeah so hey so
if you're an alcohol Pavilion so it's 21
up let's just call it a day like this
was an enormous relief to me because
Yingling is the only beer I know to
order at bars because they're vaguely
conservative and I know how to say their
name I thought although someone
yesterday told me it was youngling I
don't know thank you the bartender is
always yeah I don't believe it but I I
think this is a nice statement partially
because it's so calm like we don't need
to make a big statement in either
direction we say this is alcohol it's
inappropriate leave it at that and again
I I feel similarly to Tim
I don't care what you're doing you know
in appropriately set age groups right I
don't think children should be at
directions but if you want to drive
through at a bar that's fine it
shouldn't be harder for an 18 year old
to get into a bar than to get or like a
17 year old to get into a bar than to
get into a drag show right like it is
weird to me that we would suddenly toke
away this line but of course we saw it
happening with all of these uh drag
queen story hours there became this idea
that in some way this culture was
acceptable to have in a family setting
but we ultimately all know it's not and
I don't understand why this is the hill
that this movement is dying on
they can win it sorry go ahead there was
a story today
there was a story today in which Warner
Brothers Discovery sponsors outfest
which is a gay film festival and they're
having what's called
um celebration of queer children which
will include Story Hour and I and I
asked the question I said well I said
why is it that every time Disney hosts
one of these things or Disney throws
their hat in the ring and this everyone
goes up in arms but did you know that
Warner Brothers Discovery has a higher
ESG score than Disney why is it that
people don't care as much when Warner
Brothers Discovery does it but that's
because a lot of people think it's
because Disney is specifically geared
towards kids so it feels more predatory
and I'm gonna say I don't think anyone
could tell you what Warner's Brothers
does like yeah Disney is so much more
commercial it's much easier to attack as
a Target it's not okay
so so that is this is in the whole event
and they're going to have a whole
section that's dedicated to queer
children to celebrating for your
children to sexualizing children
well because if you think about it if
they again if they'll go after the most
extreme thing because if they can get
you to be okay with that what could they
not get you to be okay with I think that
that's the next step I always said it
like people used to call me crazy I'm
like the first thing you know about
someone if their body washes up on a
beach is their biological sex it's
undeniable no there is their age the
article recently where an archaeologist
said it's not good science I know did
you see that I saw that which is
absolutely crazy so how how far-fetched
is it to believe that the next thing
they say is well age is totally
self-identifiable too it's actually far
more subjective like there's 18 year
olds who act 25 there's 25 year olds who
act 18 on a much more obvious level than
you know you changing your biological
sex well there was a guy who tried to
legally change his age and they told him
no it's coming though I have to go back
to we should be pushing a culture that
isn't obsessed with looking at the self
the time right like if your kid you
think maybe Gay whatever how about you
ask them how are your math scores how
about you ask them what their hobbies
are how about you ask them literally
anything else instead of obsessing about
who they may or may may or may not want
to sleep with when they become
consenting adults like it's just bizarre
to me that parents feel the need to
become weirdly involved in their
children's sexuality when they are minor
teachers involved that's weirder but
this is the awfuls this is the affluent
white female liberals well you know what
it's become it's become just the it
started off with the slow obsession over
identity politics this is just an end
result of of hierarchical identity
politics if that's where your
hierarchies in society are generated
from because we're going to have
hierarchies no matter what you're going
to have a problem
um and again my buddy told me something
interesting one time when I was on this
Pathway to searching for religion he
said humans are designed to worship
they're always going to worship
something if they're not going to
worship something bigger than them
themselves they're going to worship
their job they're going to worship their
uh you know alcohol sex whatever that
thing is and right now we have a society
that is completely worshiping the very
thing you're talking about identity
uh and so we have an absolute religion
around transgenderism right now not even
not even LGB it's t we have a religion
around the t uh because we've completely
erased a lot of lesbians because now if
you're a lesbian Johns Hopkins
University yeah did you see JK Rowell
rolling trolling them over the the they
they disavowed it they said they didn't
mean to do anything wrong sure what
happened there I didn't hear John
Hopkins University had a glossary of
like different terms for sexuality and
gender and it said a lesbian was a
non-man who loves others a non-man
attracted attracted to I would say love
and that's really important yeah because
magnets are attracted to each other and
they're not men
but they left the term men in the
definition of gay and so you're just
erasing lesbians yes you are not a
racing gay men and JK Rowling you know
was like I think we should all talk
about this just the patriarchy
reasserting itself I have to wonder
right now you see the story about a way
to do it though how they made embryos
using stem cells recently yeah like a
day or two ago so I'm kind of like
look
if they can make embryos using stem
cells
and they can grow farm animals in
plastic bags
how far away are we
from humans just no longer giving birth
yeah and they just say from now on like
I really do think there there is a
potential future if we lose this culture
War where there's going to be like two
you know 35 year old women and one's
going to be like no
tell me you're you're not serious
unnatural birth you are going to destroy
your body that's already happening
C-sections are on the rise in the U.S
and I mean not even that they're going
to be like use it use a pseudo
baby I'm arguing to your point I think
we are moving in that direction already
they are saying you should not have a
natural birth you should always have
there's always reasons that doctors are
pushing for C-sections these days
whether it be risk whether it be oh well
you know there might be this issue or
like this is just more controlled we'll
know when the baby's coming and it's
something that people are becoming
normalized to now hold on hold on if we
get to that point and we are also very
close to the designer baby period China
has already had several stories about
super soldier program where they're
genetically modifying humans to make
them more resilient more robust stronger
taller et cetera if people then start
going
to
they're doctors to plan for their babies
and the doctors outright say we no
longer need women to have babies
when people are choosing the traits for
their kids what is what is the the
reason they would choose a woman
I mean that sincerely I'm not saying
there isn't one I'm saying what do you
guys think they would say because I feel
like when it comes to strength height uh
social status and and this is coming
from the left perspective of patriarchy
parents are going to be like let's just
choose a boy so there are certain
obviously uh benefits to like women have
historically always been better at
certain things like creating communities
empathy and those things will still need
to exist in society of course but I
think in the short term you're going to
have parents being like very liberal
very leftist but going but we do know
that patriarch is real so let's not
subject a daughter to that let's let's
have a young boy there'll be quotas or
they'll have a girl who then they want
to transition to give away
extra step or we'll literally get to the
point where you just don't have
genitalia and you're just completely
non-binary and true non-binary maybe
maybe that one's a ways off but I I do
think the first step before that is you
will likely just see parents being like
boys are going to be easier let's just
deal with that we don't need to worry
about grandkids anymore I sort of think
the opposite I think there's so much
antipathy towards men that people are
more likely to be angry about uh having
male babies I've had people say to me
like oh I really wouldn't want to have a
boy like a boy are you kidding me like
there is a lot of anti-man sentiment
that starts when you're having a boy and
Fair Point it may go the other way it
may be parents being like we don't want
to make the patriarchy worse that's not
a girl or provide more toxic masculinity
I think real quick if they move in the
direction of only girls
there could be a potential future where
the planet is 97 female and the
scientists and the presidents and the
military they're like we need to find
men there's just no Y chromosomes
everywhere and then some genetic disease
will start impacting the population and
they'll be like where are the men and
then like guys will be like hiding in a
cave because they want to take their
genetics or something sci-fi movie how
about this playing Xbox in a cave
I would watch that so it's always like
the male patriarchy is oppressing us
women and they're a Decay though of our
like I read there's a decay of the
chromosome I think it's Plastics
the testosterone is dropping sperm
counts dropping the chromosomes breaking
up I think it's Plastics also in terms
of electromagnetism yeah but also
surrounded by Wi-Fi and computer sorry
but in the terms of what we're talking
about with births uh and natural births
and stuff like that when you talk about
what we were talking about earlier which
is the worship of self we're seeing the
rise of surrogacy because they don't
want to actually have kids themselves
they want to pay somebody else to have
the kid for them so it's like no matter
what way you go you're not having a
natural birth at all and then we have
people coming out saying they're having
a harder time connecting with those kids
because they didn't actually pair bond
with them in the same way and that's on
the rise every bit as much and oddly
enough also only available to the super
wealthy or to the people that can afford
it the thing it bothers me so much that
people didn't realize it would be hard
to bond with children that you didn't
carry because we have had centuries of
adoption right like this this is
something that we are still doing there
are always children who need homes and
if you look into it for even a second
this is something everyone talks about
that you it's not not easy but you have
to build a bond with a child you adopt
at any age and the fact that we would be
so arrogant to be like well I
specifically paid for this child so of
course I'll love it and it'll love me
like yeah it's a designer it's like
you're saying it's a designer child you
go pick it it's like saying your dog
doesn't like you like you you I bought
this puppy why doesn't it like my house
it's crazy yep it's very scary when you
disconnect yourself completely from the
reality of your actions another thing
pushed by the media the the decay of
actually supporting families that bond
with each other right like I said chosen
family they want you to go and choose
your family based on uh whatever your
immutable characteristics are outside of
your biological connection to someone
else it's about what you look like or
who you have sex with that's what they
seem to think matters to people but
that's that's a great control tactic as
well because you get people outside the
strongest Bonds in their life yeah and
so you take them into an area where they
can control you same reason they got rid
of religion same way people from
religion because people people are far
more easier to far easier to control and
they're far more likely to worship their
own self if they don't believe in
something greater than them that keeps
them in I think also chosen family you
know I think there are lots of different
types of families that are successful
but this concept of chosen family that
accepts you for who you are exactly as
you say you are is different from honest
true love that you get from real
families your real family will be like
hey I love you but I think you're
harming yourself hey I love you but like
I want more for you I want better for
you and I don't think chosen family has
that type of structure I don't think
that there's the accountability there
you get to say you should love me
exactly as I am there's no one to push
back and say like are you sure you're
going down the right path so yeah I
think real love is ugly in many ways and
I think that's what people aren't
willing to acknowledge nowadays they
think real love should be easy and
should be beautiful and you look at
relationships we've we've become so
comfortable just detaching from things
so quickly because there's a million
options out there
um and so it's very easy to just say
accept me as I am and find someone who
will accept you as you are at least
temporarily you know and so it's it's
super easy to jump out of one
relationship to another and if you don't
have bonds with people who are really
willing to break you down and tell you
I'm doing this because I love you like
even we've even done that with families
we've told parents they're not allowed
to parents strict you know we're not
allowed to to be harsh to our kids we're
not allowed to say no to our kids and
what you do when you do that is you
create a child who's very much going to
grow up and not be able to experience
that anywhere else and if you don't
affirm their gender California will come
and take your children from you now and
you are an evil evil devil yep who is uh
who is breaking down your poor child but
also remember body positivity and
everybody's beautiful uh sometimes
unless you think it's wrong then then
you can destroy it everybody everybody
is beautiful unless it's an ideal body
and then it's you know part of the
patriarchy yes there you have to push
back on them because those are
unrealistic beauty standards which is
hard to believe considering they're
actually realistic because they actually
exist if you look if you look at every
message that's put out it's almost like
they're all designed to kill us
literally like the fat celebrating thing
like a fat you're fat shaming me and uh
I mean that is the most obvious one I'm
like what I have to celebrate the fact
that you're at higher risk for and again
I don't believe in shaming people who
are overweight but I don't believe in
celebrating it any more than I believe
in celebrating someone who smokes or
someone who drinks alcohol excessively
or anything that will lead to your early
death they don't believe in a middle
ground there they believe that anything
that is not it's kind of like when they
talk about like a lot of the YouTubers
that'll watch they'll be like whenever
they talk about somebody that they're
they're arguing with or that they
disagree with they say don't contact
this person anything you say to them
that is not 110 affirmation of
everything they believe will be seen as
an insult and as an attack so they
believe that anything that is not 110
affirming every aspect of who they are
the decisions they've made the person
that they they've become is somehow an
attack on them as a person when we
understand that the world is not that
black and white like a lack of
self-confidence though yes it is doesn't
that feel like if you don't celebrate me
then I must be doing something wrong
it's ridiculous and I think I think I
think one of the core problems is that
we've boiled all love down to sort of
this idolized worship often rude and
sexuality you know what I mean like I
think we forget that there are all kinds
of ways to love someone and support
someone that doesn't mean that you fall
over backwards trying to say that
they're the best thing of all times and
everything they do is right right all
the time I think that we
are uh devoid of emotional uh
nuance and we don't know how to talk
about it and we have to boil everything
down to either Europe before me or
you're against me if I saw a kid with
their parent mom or dad an ice cream
shop and the kid was screaming I want
more ice cream and the parent was like
okay okay and then gave the kid more ice
cream and the kid shoveled it down and
said I want more I want more and the kid
was like overweight I beg man those
parents don't love that kid at all I I
had a friend who said something super
interesting to me once uh about
relationships and because he's like he's
he he fights a lot early on in his
relationships with his partners and he's
like that's the time where everyone says
you should be in your little fantasy
period where everything should be great
you should you know the fights should
come later it's a bad sign he's like no
he's like I want to get I want to know
early on I want to set these healthy
boundaries early on so we know we know
right away you can't be scared of that
you can't be scared of tension you can't
be scared of not being agreeable with
someone you have to be willing to kind
of face that fire and if something's not
right for you if it's not right for them
that's okay you have to be able to
communicate that and then you can work
through it if it's worth it uh but again
we've become a society that says the
second anything is wrong the second
someone doesn't support you exactly the
way you are even if it's entirely
detrimental to your well-being that
they're the problem you're not the
problem but it's but it is changing I
think we're starting to recognize that
affirmation is not care it's the
opposite of that if someone comes to you
and says they think they should be skin
and bones we have interventions for this
and no you need to eat food but for some
reason there are a bunch of elements to
human behavior where everyone's
affirming it including morbid obesity
and they're letting these people make
these claims like it's not a choice
there's this woman who's uh flying on a
plane saying they should it's
discrimination to make them buy more
than one seat because they just saw that
she wants three seats for free yeah can
I ask you a question what do you guys
see if you play all these individual
things out to their final level
what do you see the end result as a
collapse complete collapse and then just
like a rebuild kind of yeah like uh I
think it may happen you know like things
break down the system never truly goes
away people survive they'll keep working
I think the cities are on the verge of
collapse I mean actually I think SF is
dead the so something happens to
um the how malls close when one store
closes then people stop going to the
mall which lowers foot traffic for other
for other stores which causes more
stores to close and then it causes this
Cascade effect that's happening to
downtown San Francisco oh yeah their
hotels are being uh surrendered the mall
is not being surrendered it's only 55 at
least when there's no reason to go
downtown people will stop moving there
people will stop working there and then
the less people are there the less
people need to be there the more it'll
collapse that's going to happen to the
rest of our cities too you believe that
across the United States do you believe
there's certain cities that will be
strongholds against look at Detroit
right massive population uh depart like
flight out of the state I I don't think
it means the cities will just cease to
exist I'm saying that as hubs they'll
just not they won't be I agree with that
and you could say it's technological too
like there's no reason to be there
anymore because we can all work on zoom
and stuff for the most part but I think
we are going to see these cities that
are Rife with crime and other conflict
and Chaos they're going to become
undesirable and cheap it's going to be
like an inversion of the rural versus
the the the urban
yeah I think it's just such a shame
because I think California has so much
to offer on a nature level on an
entertainment level it's just like it's
a really cool place but I think
California is a great example there are
people who live outside of cities who
would never leave California they love
it it's it's the city center that's the
problem and the infrastructure that goes
with it someone uh we just got a super
chat from uh a a roncha who said we have
the store I just pulled it up a t to
close Downtown San Francisco flagship
store
I can only wonder why I didn't read the
story we just pulled up they say
consumer shopping habits continue to
change and we're changing with them that
means serving customers where they are
through the right mix of retail stores
digital channels and our phone based
care team he said there's still two ATT
locations within one mile of their
financial district store the closure
isn't unique to SF the Union Square
store will shutter August 1st a similar
store in Chicago on Michigan Avenue will
close in the same day leaving the
nation's only 18t flagship store in
Dallas interesting I wonder why Dallas I
wonder what Texas might be doing to
where they're okay keeping their store
open but uh Chicago and SF I think that
somebody was just walking into the a t
store one day and they're just like
that's just one crack needle too many
they on their foot they're just like
sorry that's enough heroin in my feet
for one day you know when they have to
put all their phones behind vaults yeah
didn't Walmart just say that in San
Francisco also that they're they're
eventually I think they're going to shut
down but now they have everything
there's no way Walmart is closing uh
stores across the country because of
crime yeah I mean and Walgreens is
everywhere and for a lot of people
Walmart is a is their main grocery store
it's their main access to food and so
this is a big problem there's a I think
a Walgreens I think it's in Chicago
where you walk in there's no products
there's a wall with a with an iPad and
you walk up and type it that's what I
was talking about Chicago I thought it
was San Francisco and then they they
bring the items out to you after you pay
wow man it's really funny because I
remember when Amazon wanted to launch
that store where you didn't there's no
cashiers you walk in grab whatever you
want walk out it automatically charges
you yeah I I reached out to uh to Amazon
After figuring out a very simple way of
bypassing the system
and they said effectively what I was
told was that uh shrinkage doesn't
matter that much because they save so
much money on overhead by not having the
staff to do to check out that they can
absorb those costs expected
but it is fascinating that they thought
they could do something like that I
really don't think that'll work out in
the long run because if people aren't
scared to steal and walk past security
what do you think is going to happen
when they walk into building and there's
no nothing there's nobody yeah they're
gonna walk and take whatever they want
walk out what are you gonna do about it
you think a cop's gonna go find a guy
because he took ten dollars of the food
ain't gonna happen especially not in San
Francisco if they have any there I mean
they're not even allowed to engage the
police even if they do well there's the
uh the thousand dollar limit in SF so if
Amazon really tries to do these
futuristic cashier list stores people
are going to walk in and be like it's
not even illegal to just take whatever
you want I mean it's if if you're
incentivizing people to steal I've sadly
learned this in life is that human
nature does not always lean toward the
best behavior it tends to inherently
head toward the worst and and you have
to deter people on some level uh and so
it's you know I have friends who work in
department stores and they're like we're
not even allowed to even say anything do
you have a physical store for their
watches nope no retailers I I don't want
an egg you know it would be cool to have
a like eggard physical store that would
just have a showcase and uh I would like
it just for the kind of legacy of the
company maybe in Florida in Florida
where I live now I ran away from
California as well I was going to say
because it's probably the only safe
place you know yeah you can set up in
West Virginia you'd be pretty good there
but in terms of higher density foot
traffic in a big Urban store Florida's
probably your best bet I think so too I
think Florida's a I mean I have I have a
buddy who opened a sunglass store over
there and he's you know he's doing
really well Florida's just become such a
crazy Hub of over the past two years
three years it's just exploded yeah
um so especially South Florida where I
am it's it's just the amount of change
so quickly scares me on some level
because I'm like this cannot be
sustainable but so long as people are
flooding out of those States you talk
about they're going to keep flooding
into other states in Florida Texas those
are really desirable well come on let's
think about it you have choices here you
can live in San Francisco where you're
going to step in human poop or you can
live in Florida where there are
beautiful men on the beach Ceviche nice
man comes and brings you pina colada
you're sitting back you put your feet up
no drag shows for kids none of that I
don't know you choose is there any worry
that like there's a constant worry right
that when people flock out of these
cities that they're they don't really
think it through entirely and then they
end up bringing their voting habits to
these other states and then you have to
worry about those States eventually
slowly transforming over time because
they don't connect in their brain that
the things they were voting for were
what yeah I was gonna say they never
promised to leave their voting habits no
they don't I think I think DeSantis has
proven that to not be a something we
should fear because he got a million new
votes because he's the exception though
because of the Cuban vote and the fear
of socialism you do not necessarily have
that from a left-leaning liberal who
leaves California but Texas also did see
a redshift yeah and didn't they also
heavily restrict mail-in ballots in both
those States they may have yeah that
could also be a big factor
um I think two things I think we talked
about this before when uh Elon and Rogan
leave California for Texas it's not that
they are bringing their policies it's
they bring staff the employees work with
their companies are not conservatives
and if they have to relocate for work or
say hey it's an opportunity then you're
bringing liberal voters that is scary to
me yep if Florida goes down
I gotta run away again the last question
well there's always West Virginia all
right but we we've we've got our stuff
happening in West Virginia too yeah
oh I don't know if I should talk about
it just yet maybe we should wait yeah
probably yeah but man now I feel so
there's just there's just woke stuff
happening in West Virginia oh really and
you know the it's it's the second most
Trump supporting state in the country
it's like 86 support for Trump most
people here are every county in the
state went for Trump right and they're
and they're even even where it's like
potentially mixed it leans still for
Trump it's close but uh most people here
who aren't even staunch conservative are
just in agreement with us on most of
these issues and you're seeing this
stuff emerge and I think it's because
the average person doesn't care and I
think it's because conservatives don't
engage in community activism so the the
fundamental problem I see for
conservatives in general there's there's
like a multi-faceted kind of problem
here that I see happening I think one of
the first things that you you see that's
really bad for conservatives is that
they rely so much on individuality as
opposed to uh kind of like a hive
mentality that you see on the left it's
just far more effective because once you
have a sense of kind of that Hive
mentality it's this that warm and fuzzy
feeling I was telling you about in
Hollywood it's a really good feeling
when you show up on set and it's warm
and everyone's friends with you and you
feel important the left is very good at
creating that sentiment across the the
board on everything they do with
messaging with community and the right
lacks in that department they're not
emotionally driven in their advertising
and their messaging and their movies
like because they feel it in the family
they they keep that aspects for the
family for the family side of things
whereas the other side looks to find it
in their profession it's an advantage
though it is they also they also
Coalition build better and they they go
door to door like I've never had a
right-wing political candidate ever come
door to door to me with you know with
you know people reaching out to say Hey
how do you feel about this person do you
want to vote for this person but I've
certainly had a lot of people uh come to
my door like there's people like when it
was like Craig Ellis and in Minnesota
was like they're like oh he's here for
attorney general I'm like isn't that the
guy who beat his wife and they're like I
don't know about that I'd have to check
on that like you know but they're they
like in that time period before that
election I had three four candidates all
Democrats had people coming door to door
to talk to you about it and I just us
don't see that do you think part of that
is because you were in a liberal City
and so Republicans saw it as lost ground
already I didn't see the point in
battling it out I don't know how it how
the voting goes because like where I
lived out there was fairly unique I was
uh in either direction I was a mile from
what would have been an urban center
meaning that that would have gone
heavily blue but then to the you know a
mile the other way and I'm in a fairly
nice and a very nice suburb but it
doesn't really matter for the voting
yeah so I don't know where you know but
you didn't vote in the suburb you voted
in the city center like that's what you
were voting for so yeah they probably
saw it as a lost cause well these were
no these were state level elections
these weren't even County or anything
like this so these would have been
people like he this is attorney general
for the state right so that's they could
have gone through the whole area it
wouldn't have mattered so I don't think
it would have been seen as ground loss I
just know that in my I get more text
messages you know the you get random
text messages it's never even under my
name it's for some person it's like I've
been getting text message for a guy
named Masood for like a decade and I
just never unsubscribed to it because I
just expect it now I like invited my
suit out for dinner I look forward well
no they think I'm missing have you
thought about voting for this person I'm
like I'm still massoud it's kind of nice
but you know on those on those lonely
nights you're sitting there and you're
really going around it's dark and then
your phone vibrates and you smile yeah
it feels good to be massages
no I think that uh Republicans famously
are terrible at their ground game right
like that's that's not anything new what
bothers me more is that they it's their
off season right like we get it you're
terrible I can say it 100 times get
better at going to the door find some
more Innovative voter registration
strategy what bothers me more is in the
off Seasons right now it's pride month
we're all these Pride parades we're
seeing all these things these are
moments where you're getting people who
are like-minded together in a
non-election year there are not
equivalents for conservatives right like
where are the I mean some states have
them but like more county fairs I would
like lots of Fourth of July like blocks
I want more things that non-political
slash leaning conservative people can go
to and connect with other people and
talk about hey what's going on in our
community or our state or our nation
right I feel like that's what we are
missing the off off your community
events and and the fun behind it yeah
like they're missing there's a
disconnect somewhere in conservative
messaging and events and I don't like
maybe it's because I'm like a hyper
artistic person I'm kind of like in that
sense I'm very liberal-minded and
there's a disconnect for me and I can't
put my finger on it with a lot of the
stuff that is for the right where I
don't even want to attend the event I
don't even I don't know what it is I
can't nail it down I think it's
something I I don't know how much anyone
follows this but like the New York and
Republicans have really exploded as a
club in the past couple years and it's
they made it fun they do fun events they
do they have interesting speakers it's
it's a community group and I think this
is something that we are missing I think
it's easy for a lot of uh left leading
people to get together when they feel
outraged and they're going against the
machine even though we know they kind of
are on the machine at this point uh and
conservatives don't have those Community
moments my favorite thing that Trump has
said is that we need to have like a
year-long celebration for the 250th
anniversary of America right like less
let's do this like that sounds fun even
if you're not super into politics it's
just fun to have fun things to do you
know what I think it is with the art I
think when when it comes for the art
like you said you're liberal minded when
it comes to our you know Artistic
Endeavors it's because when the right
creates art a lot of the times it reeks
of a sense of desperation to win back
something yes that I don't like I I I
don't maybe I'm upsetting some people
but I heard the the 81 million Vote song
and I just I'm like
just like that this isn't this isn't
working like it like there is whether
you like their messaging or not there is
more natural artistic Drive uh on the
left side of things and now it's shoved
into the entertainment full force now
but it wasn't always like that right so
yeah they could Coalition uh you know
better you know build better and I do
like the idea of more you know more
things that celebrate the country right
more fun but isn't it sad that anything
that celebrates the country is now
inherently a political issue rather than
a bipartisan one well that's nuts in
itself we we've got breaking news that I
want to bring up this is uh from Fox
News thousands protests sisters of
Perpetual Indulgence outside Dodger
Stadium hours before start of Pride
night and uh we can see someone Super
Chat of Bill M saying Dodger Stadium
entrance shut down by protests
so if those are familiar this is a hate
group whose sole intention is to insult
and mock Christians and Catholics in
particular and they are being uh given
the opportunity to to perform uh their
hate speech at Dodger Stadium now for me
I'm all about the First Amendment stuff
like that so typically it's like you
know if you're if you're going to have a
group and they want to speak their mind
and they want to put on a show or
whatever I'm typically okay with it
however in Los Angeles they have very
very strict rules against this so it's
it's surprising that law enforcement
allowed this hate speech to persist and
uh and and force the good citizens
seeking social justice to come and
protest I would also want to know why
the hell so many things have nothing to
do with drag shows now have to do with
Dragons what does Sports have to do with
it
everything who the hell in the in the
good name of middle management was like
you know what would be a good idea we
should have this group like what does
that have to do with baseball giving uh
Straight girls who make Pride about
themselves I feel like it drag has never
ever been as popular until all of these
people who had no interest in dag
decided we needed drag shows everywhere
but I want to pull I have this tweet
from uh Savannah Hernandez thousands of
Catholics have shut down the main
entrance to Dodger Stadium on Vince
Gully Avenue in protest of the Citrus
sisters of Perpetual Indulgence being
honored tonight they are now lining the
sidewalks and have taken over the entire
block I mean this is what we're talking
about talking about conservatives who
need to to stand up and protest and I
gotta point out too I probably shouldn't
even say conservative many of them
probably are many of them may be
Catholic but uh Savannah says thousands
of Catholics perhaps there are thousands
of Catholics but I'm willing to bet
there are a lot of just regular
angelenos who are like Hey we're not
okay with this kind of performance
Minstrel show and not all Catholics are
conservative right there are liberal
Catholics who would see this as an
insult to their faith it's like we
forget that there are pro-life Democrats
they're a minority yeah but their party
gave them away we don't talk about these
things because we have decided that you
know most are like this but if you were
a left-leaning if you were a liberal
Catholic this would be just as insulting
to your Faith as if you were a
conservative I do have a feeling that
Sheamus would tell you there aren't
liberal Catholics there are I know there
definitely are but are they really
Catholics then if they're appalling I
mean certainly I think there are a lot
of Catholics who disagree about Vatican
can you be a pro-choice Catholic
no I would say no but I am not a
practicing Catholic it's not my my
decision to uh well what I will say is
there's certain certain things and this
kind of gives me hope a little bit
there's certain uh areas of weakness
like cracks in the structure of the left
where they lose their own party and I
think these are some of the ones you see
like the trans issue the vax issue you
know when they get too extreme on
certain issues that go against Common
Sense Minnesota just didn't Minnesota
just legalize late term like late late
term abortion and that was just I
believe so that was just like just a
couple of years ago I was talking to
someone because like I said I'm from
Minnesota and I was talking to someone I
was explaining about Ralph Northam and
what was going on and all of these
things are like that sounds crazy that's
not real I'm like no no you have to read
this you have to read the bill you have
to read through all these things uh and
then they're like well that's that's
very fringed it's not going to expand
that was a couple years ago and like
that will never come here I'm like
that'll come here before it'll come a
lot of a lot of other places given the
way that Minnesota is uh BLM activists
who just got arrested in Canada or
charged in Canada uh for an
anti-catholic hate crime she blocked a
Catholic school and couldn't like people
can get in I guess and uh she was also a
very serious
um pro-abortion activist she led a huge
rally in Calgary and was interviewed and
she was saying we need to speak out
about the potential this is after the
row uh decision leaked and she was
saying we need to speak out because
what's happening in America could spread
to Canada they could take away our
rights to abortion uh if if they think
it could happen shouldn't we think it
could happen right you know I thought
the timing of the Roe v Wade uh decision
was a bad move for conservatives I
thought it really hurt I had a big
debate with my dad at the time he's like
people don't care as much as you think
I'm like people are single party voters
and they vote emotionally and you know
uh when what's his name from Barstool
Sports uh came out and was like I'm
voting left if they they go on fortnite
made some kind of speech about voting
democratic this happens and I was like
man people people are so so weird in
their decision to just like outrageously
like no no no that makes sense report
Noy I mean his argument and I'm not I'm
saying this with in all seriousness I
thought his argument was that if he
knocks up a woman he doesn't want to
have the kid oh that's a fair argument
for being pro-choice I personally find
it morally
um as I find it to be morally repugnant
yeah but at least he's consistent in his
uh but I don't wanna I don't want to
assign views to him I don't know if
that's 100 true I just remember people
saying something like I think he said
something about that like yo I feel like
up with a chicken she gets she gets
pregnant or whatever like you gotta have
that choice or something like that
that's what it's because of ease a
society of ease let me just double check
that I'll make sure I'm right no but
that makes sense I mean that really does
make sense yeah plenty of friends who
are like yes I am very in support uh
support of your abortion rights because
I don't want to have to take any
responsibility if I screw up or we
always say it's women but I think there
are a lot of men who are like no please
everything everything that women are
pushing nowadays men are secretly very
like women are like I want the right to
be promiscuous it's like I wasn't Andrew
Schultz do a whole bit about this he's
like we agree feminine he's like he goes
the feminists of today are the F boys of
five years yeah and guys are like what
do you tell me you don't want me to pay
for you you don't want to work free the
nipple yeah I agree yeah yeah do you
want to pay for all the stuff so dude
let's get down here let's clarify I
don't have anything of him saying
anything like that he's literally just
giving the traditional uh left argument
women's Choice it's their right
Constitution Etc all right I mean I mean
either way I'm sure there are other men
who have made that argument I I sort of
disagree I think you know obviously it
was bizarre for the for the leak but I
think the timing of Roe v Wade was good
for the conservative base I think
conservatives felt like it was a win
like yes maybe there were moderates who
got freaked out by it and moved the
other way but you're always battling
over maybe they could have gotten that
one after them I think that's that's
what at the timing of it is no I think I
mean midterms are are a debacle in a lot
of ways but I think generally seeing
that the Supreme Court was going to
change this decision was something that
uh helped conservatives I think they
felt like it re-energized them because
it for so long I think a lot of
conservatives feel like they are
battling an uphill uh they are battling
uphill to defend their values and keep
them here they're always having to
compromise on everything and it was the
one time in a long time that they have
been like oh no we were right this was a
bad idea the Supreme Court says it
should go back to the stage which was
the also the crazy thing because the
left went into hysterics about this and
they were like you're challenging
abortion everywhere it's like kind of if
your state wants to have it you can and
yes it does again it's the messaging and
there and and the right never gets an
opportunity to put out the right message
you'll never get the media to to back a
message that's right so like I've even
made arguments to people who uh are very
left-leaning and I've gotten them on
board with uh with it by just saying I
don't think the government should have a
say one way or the other because they
could eventually lead to a complete
restriction on it if you feel like they
should be uh which is what they try to
ask Trump about at the Town Hall like
this is they are only operating they
only want this to be a federal issue the
fact that this is the compromise it's a
state's issue as it always should have
been is not enough I disagree I don't
think it should be a state issue really
yeah I think uh overturning Roe v Wade
is wrong it should be a federal issue it
should be Federal federally regulated no
I feel like you think it should be
federally regulated yeah I think I'm I I
don't know exactly what my view was
around the time this was uh overturned I
think we were all fairly in agreement
over it we've had a lot of conversations
about it and I think that it should be
Federal federally regulated under the
14th Amendment
um or because of the 14th Amendment I
think the federal government has to
ensure uh equal rights under the law to
to all life
that doesn't mean I think abortion
should be banned I don't I think it just
means that we can't have two standards
of when someone is allowed to get an
abortion because it terminates a life
there is no point in history where an
arbitrary definition of personhood has
not resulted in the math Mass death of a
group right and and so you know where we
are is I I'm traditionally I'm in the
more traditional pro-choice Camp which
is up to a certain amount of weeks
government stays out of it after a
certain point it's the baby can survive
the baby should not be killed that's my
view I think the federal government
should regulate it of course rovey Waits
overturns it doesn't matter but um it
could go to Congressional legislation
if Trump and Republicans sweep you could
end up with like a 12-week nationwide
ban if the federal government I just
feel like it should always we should
always defer power to the states rather
than the federal government I believe I
agree with you we want to have a an
equal application of uh equal protection
under the law and I I personally believe
life begins a conception right but I
think putting power in the hands of
federal government is always a mistake
but then you're saying that California
has the right to restrict free speech
how so this is the 14th Amendment
question do we as life human life have
equal rights under the law the answer is
yes we do well the question then becomes
and you're making the argument if by
your own argument then there should be a
complete ban of abortion across the
board no conception nope the the issue
is when it comes to two by two two life
forms inhabiting the same body I don't
believe the federal government has the
right to order someone provide their
body and blood to another person there
you go there's a competing rights issue
with abortion absolutely so you have two
bodies however how can we at
acknowledging this that there's
competing rights allow two different
states to have two different standards
for what the Constitution is supposed to
enforce so that means it's up to
federally uh it's up to the federal
government to interpret or for
legislation to codify how the 14th
amendment should apply to uh unborn
persons the left's principal argument is
life doesn't begin a conception they
have to make that argument otherwise the
fourth amendment is clear abortion is
completely illegal
um or I should say restricted up until
like 12 to 16 weeks I do not see how you
could argue the Constitution guarantees
the rights of all citizens except we
allow the states to determine when and
where those rights start and stop right
you can't well the problem is again with
definitions of personhood and again I
think any or any made-up definition of
personhood other than it is a human life
you know by your own definition is a
dangerous one even in a competing rights
issue because you're comparing two
different rights you're not competing of
the right to life of the mother to the
right to life of the fetus you're
comparing the right to terminate because
of dependency to the right to life and
so the right to terminate or the right
of dependency is a much lesser right
than your right to life in other words
if I connected you to me right now and
we had a Accord by my own choice by my
own action I forced your dependence onto
me and I said now that you are dependent
on me I have the right to kill you you
would say well no my right to life is
bigger than your right especially that
it is through your own action to depend
on me now you can make the argument in
rape and instance in those cases that
doesn't hold because I don't think the
incest one applies because there's no
con yeah as long as there is no consent
to the ACT that argument makes sense but
when you take action to create a life
and then you try and say well there's a
competing rights issue no it's not an
equal right and you took action to
create that right through consent to
create that situation through concern
early on I was very much saying like oh
it's good that the states are taking
control of this issue which it should go
to the states and things like that now I
I I very much don't think so because of
the Constitution and because of the 14th
Amendment which means I think
Republicans should legislate this and
they my view is it should be like I
don't know maybe 16 weeks or something
which is such a difficult difficult
difficult subject no they never end up
they never will end up doing that on
either side because it's too much of a
money maker when you're it makes them
way too much money when they're raising
campaign funds why Obama never ratified
and why we kept it out right entirely
because they have to continue to
campaign on the need to continue to
campaign for it so it'll just always
yeah it's almost like the pharmaceutical
industry let's take a look at the
purpose of the 14th Amendment it emerges
after the Civil War it's to guarantee
that those who were enslaved in this
country are recognized as citizens of
this country it also guarantees equal
treatment under the law for all
individuals
there is no logical scientific or even
moral basis to argue that life does not
begin at conception there they they can
make every argument in the world they
want but life literally begins a
conception this is when a unique set of
DNA is created to any degree then they
make these arguments about how like oh
so when a woman has a miscarriage or
whatever it's an abortion no one said
that we're talking uh the crime requires
intent and then there is the
complications of
um competing interests competing rights
and that's why I'm like it's not so
simple to say ban abortion outright yeah
I also think you can't just be like
California says you can in Colorado you
know California and Colorado say you can
Texas says you can't because if we're
talking about
we we cannot allow states to determine
what what is a human and what is not
like we we have to codify that look
that's a great argument and I actually
would rethink my position on that based
on that argument what I would there's
there's an argument that Ben Shapiro
makes that actually kind of upsets me
when he says that women lack the men's
Raya to know that they're committing a
crime because they've lived in a society
that's taught them that it's not a Life
by that argument a white supremacist
who's been taught that a Jew is a rat or
a cockroach and goes and kills a Jew
lacks the men's reaction
I don't buy it either I I do think even
conservatives and pro-lifers don't truly
believe the um the flat morality of
their statements when pro-lifers say
that a baby is alive and abortion is
killing a baby I always ask a very
simple question to which they always
reject and that is
I'll ask you now
if you came across an individual who was
on the verge and declared his intent to
take the life of another person would
you intervene to save that person yes
if you saw a doctor about to perform an
abortion on a baby at eight months and
said I will now take the life of this
baby would you intervene to save that
baby yes you would yes the average
person says says absolutely not well 100
I would intervene you would stop a
doctor give him the opportunity
consequence of law you're talking about
like I'm going to be arrested because
just just in general I mean consequence
eight months fetus absolutely so most
concerns I say absolutely not they say
no I wouldn't I wouldn't do that that's
different and it's and and I'm you know
is there argument there that like look I
don't know if that doctor is performing
it to save the mother that's a whole
other argument so so so the typical
answer I get and you know I respect your
your your your candor the average
conservative I've asked on this show has
just been like no I wouldn't you know I
was like they're performing and I'm like
so you do see it differently you don't
see it exactly the same but it sounds
like you do I see a abortion at eight
months where there is no medical risk if
it's again under extenuating
circumstances which again I might argue
the same thing thing of self-defense if
someone was about to kill you and you
were about to fight back and kill them
I'd be like okay I wouldn't intervene
but uh in the sense of it's just an
abortion there's no risk to the woman
other than what is normally expected in
a pregnancy yes I would intervene and
say that that is very disturbing it's
also is it also still considered like in
states where abortion is legal does it
also still considered double murder if
you end up killing a pregnant mother so
it's there's no there's liberal states
that's it yeah that is you can get
charged to the double murder yeah so in
this documentary I shot one of the
things I did is I interviewed people and
one of the and we did it in LA uh where
everyone is very pro-choice and one of
the first questions I ask them is that
exact question if there's a man who
dates a woman she gets pregnant uh three
four months down the road he decides he
doesn't want the baby so he stabs the
woman and she dies and the baby dies is
that double homicide they all said yes
and I said it's abortion The Taking of a
life and they said no and they're they
try to rationalize it so hard you saw
the virus we had on this show with the
the leftists who said that he believes a
windshield abortions whenever they want
but that women shouldn't be allowed to
do math because meth intentionally kills
the baby and I'm just like you know come
on so you can do it you just can't have
fun while you're doing it yeah
what we need is rule of law
I think back to you know I read a lot
about the Civil War considering
and the problem is you have different
states with a different standard on what
is a human life and what constitutes
human rights and now you have the
argument over whether or not an unborn
baby is a human life but it
unquestionably is by all medical
standards by every definition and then
the left comes up with arguments that
it's not a human life because of
sentience because of emotion or whatever
we've even had a leftist on the show
argue I said when do you think Life
Begins he's at some point after birth
and I'm like well that's just not legal
it's not moral like so there are some
very serious and complicated moral
questions that pertain to how this stuff
happens in this country well personhood
over human life is the danger right
because personhood usually is argued as
sentience or self-consciousness
self-awareness and self-awareness could
arguably happen at three years old
logical thinking at 11. okay are they
saying that then they're not going to
assign you your social security number
or your birth certificate until you've
had your first conscious thought like I
don't know what they're like that
doesn't hold water oh I had I I debated
someone on abortion they literally told
me that it should be allowed up and if
you don't have a special security card
You're Not a Human Being I so you know
thinking about the overturning of Roe v
Wade and why I think it's probably wrong
is that this is more likely to lead us
to civil conflict in this country
because what was a federally settled
issue and I think what I'm basically
saying is that like the original
interpretation probably was that was the
better one
the issue is now you have States in
active conflict over a personhood
question
and that's not going to go well
we also have to ask the same question
about these these um child sex exchange
operations that are happening in these
other states when they can take
someone's kid away and then reject
subpoenas and warrants I think the the
challenge is when the federal government
seeds a constitutional personhood ruling
you'll end up with States at extreme
moral odds with each other where we are
now and then a certain point someone
just says I can't allow this evil to
persist in this country and they're not
going to wait for legislation and that's
a dark a dark thing I guess I'd rather
have the debate right I'd rather have
the debate over personhood happen at
State levels because I think that's more
effective in changing Minds
perhaps but I just feel like it makes
the argument that any constitutional uh
right can be can be legislated on in any
state I think we should have a debate
then I I always I mean like I don't I
think my rights aren't up for vote and
if the Constitution guarantees are
keeping our arms no State should be
allowed to restrict it I think by
legislating at the Federal which may be
the right thing to do it's just my
opinion that making returning more power
to federal government is always a
mistake
I think personally that we should have
as much debate about our rights
constantly all the time because that's
the only way to defend them and I think
if you want to convert people's minds
about when life begins it's more likely
to be effective at the state level if
someone who doesn't believe you cures
well they made it if uh you know they
passed a federal restriction on abortion
you can't have abortion after 12 weeks
they are going to see the federal
government as this oppressive
patriarchal society and they will never
change their mind out they'll see us
they are more they're not going to
change their minds
that's why I think it's better you're
more likely to win people it's not even
the Supreme Court said it goes to the
states it's that they said the Supreme
Court shouldn't rule on it yeah so the
real issue goes to Congress I'd be happy
for it to go to Congress except I think
it I just personally feel like this is
something that should be legislated at
the state level you know I came in 100
thinking the same thing as as you for a
long time actually that was my position
but if it is that if it is a
constitutional right which it is yeah
then it has to be legislated on a
federal level it cannot be legislated on
a state level for the very argument he
made if personhood is determined on a
state level you'll not only find that it
will have far varying uh descriptions
which is extremely dangerous and will be
against the Constitution but what you
will have is more extreme positions
you're going to have California
purposefully push back and say we're
allowing it until birth and you're going
to have sex what happened with Africa we
just paused all of the laws on abortion
right this is the hysteria that came in
West Virginia is going to enact their
law from the 18 whatever we are going to
see people continue to debate this so if
we get a federal law fine but until that
federal law is repealed or intact in
some way you always need to have a
fallback at the state level to decide
how are you going to regulate these
things no no finish oh I was gonna say
like I understand that at a certain
level our constitution is set at the
federal level Federal level but I think
ultimately if you don't have strong
systems in place in the states it all
falls apart as soon as the federal
government changes we're gonna go to
Super Chat so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends head over to
timcast.com become a member by clicking
join us and download the mobile app by
clicking mobile app to your Android
device
I'm not your buddy guy says Let's Help
Trump decide Personnel I think Robert
Barnes would be great for A.G ultimately
we need Trump and team to be ready to
start running like those who stormed the
beaches of Normandy
yeah I think it's I think Trump needs to
consider more based individual sports
Administration there were so many great
personalities who are big fans of trump
that were just not involved and they
should have been
all right let's grab some more
where are we where we got
the curly Afro says thanks to Chicago's
ex-mayor Rahm Emanuel now ambassador to
Japan a LGBT understanding bill was
signed into law in Japan on Friday
people here are livid they didn't want
this and the woke virus ideological
problems Western nations are facing wow
didn't Japan just raised their age of
consent from 13 to 16.
Japan's a crazy Place Japan is wild yeah
Goldilocks production says Tim occult
has been organized for your vulciferon
character and Fan Art made how does it
feel to be the leader of a based furry
cult now and that your character now has
art it feels fantastic I'd like to see
the art maybe we'll put it so do you
know about volsophone
the uh I was when I was talking about
human rights law in New York City
their their gender identity law says you
can call yourself whatever you want you
can wear whatever you want dress however
you want and companies must accommodate
as a customer or employee so I'm like
any name okay what about vociferon
Herald of the winter Mists and your your
outfit a for a wolf furry costume of
some sort or fox or something yeah the
law says it and I was told by lawyers
that they'd laugh you out of the
courtroom if you tried and I said then
what's the difference between that and a
judge laughing out a six foot three
ripped guy in a dress
you know if a judge thinks something's
ridiculous then he has the right to just
reject the law
tough questions so I'm telling people
I'm like if they really want to subject
you to these rules entertain the rules
yeah every day add one more thing to
your personality and see at what point
they finally just break down and say
please no more wasn't there the guy in
the the school the student in the school
they said you have to respect pronouns
and he changed himself to like sir
Kingston whatever he gave himself like a
royal name yeah but imagine this imagine
you work somewhere that's doing this one
day you wear a tail you clip into the
back of your pants and then you say it's
part of my identity they're probably not
going to care then the next day you know
you do that for a week that next week
you wear little paw gloves you can still
use your fingers and then they won't say
anything then the next week you wear
wolf boots
and they probably might not still say
anything then the next week you wear the
mask and now they're saying look what
are you doing you say this is part of my
identity if at this point they complain
you've now got very serious uh uh
present on your side you can say I'm
identifying this way for over a month I
have worn these items without
consequence without complaint but all of
a sudden they start taking issue with my
with my gender identity and they're
gonna ask me like has he been wearing
this stuff for a month well yeah but not
the mask but so you knew he was doing
this and you didn't say anything about
it yes well then how are you going to
complain I like that the answer is just
make it a game yeah push them you should
you should turn it into something fun
and extreme so that you test boundaries
just to see how far things those so two
that are necessary but here's how these
things these people operate these
activists they do a little bit
and so you could you tolerate it then
the next day they do a little bit more
and you tolerate it and the next day you
do a little bit more and then before you
know it a Year's gone by and
Everything's changed the the story we
like to tell us about eBay
when they first launched the website was
yellow one day they changed it to White
everybody revolted nah they were all mad
so they changed it back then from that
point on every day they slowly
incremented it one shade at a time
towards White until a year later the
website was white at no one complained
nobody noticed this is true yep well
that is a perfect tactic that's happened
in society across the board when it
comes to the vociferon thing though if
you if you were to do something like
this and you genuinely identified this
way there are a lot of people who are
furries and they genuinely decided to do
this at a certain point you're going to
see that these businesses will not allow
it but they have no choice it's the law
and so be yourself don't hold back just
because you have a fursuit where the
floor look if someone was listening is a
full full
full-on furry with the fursuit go to
work go to your job and say Hey look
it's protected I almost came here in a
furry suit opted not to what made you
change we would have respected it yeah
just pull I pulled back at the last
thing it always makes you think of like
like I always think men who are super
into the gym should go to their doctors
and ask for steroids because gender
affirming care they want to affirm how
masculine they are I never understand
why like why this hasn't happened yet
and maybe it hasn't it is trt starting
to happen trt is fantastic all right
people is fantastic John kelbaugh says I
found a short story about the idea of
using augmented reality technology to
filter out facts and opinions that you
don't agree with read the price of
consensus of r slash hfy
went there a Black Mirror episode about
that where you could block people in
real life and then they just like it
grayed out and you get banned in real
life nobody could see you it's and that
is coming that I actually believe is not
so especially with the new trend toward
augmented reality in general the new uh
Apple but but even with that stuff it's
not like you can't see underneath or
outside like no but eventually you can I
mean eventually the technology is going
to become much smaller and eventually
they're going to be quick lenses yeah
and they'll be able to erase things from
your vision and your memory they'll be
able to for sure
no you don't I don't think that Apple
headset's gonna take off because like
with phones when the smartphone came out
we were using phones for decades I can't
think of the similar devices no no no no
no no incorrect we did not use Touch
capacitive devices ever but the phone
call was something that we had
established it's like a normal routine
part of our lives and the phone call
will be the apparatus by which we get
these implants and things I'm telling
you what what I see happening is how is
that everybody got a cell phone well
some people had cell phones other people
didn't and then jobs started saying you
got a cell phone well we would really
like it if you did then it got to the
point where now if you go to a company
and you try to get a job and they'll be
like what's your cell numbers I don't
have one but
what how do we get in touch with you we
have meetings like you need a phone no I
just have a landline at home that's
unacceptable like how do we get in touch
with you I don't have email either I
just have a phone no you have to have it
so what's going to happen with neurolink
is it'll happen and then a bunch of
companies will adopt it and their
employees will just say whatever the
employees who don't like it we'll be
like well I guess I have no choice and
then within within two years you'll try
to apply for a job and they'll be like
and what's your norlink ID and you'll
say well I don't have one and they'll go
well all of our meetings are in neural
space and you'll say uh I don't have one
no but look we're if you can't make the
meetings then I don't know we can do for
you you know the the augmented reality
thing especially is an interesting one
because it's as much as people think
it's like an elitist expensive product
it's actually a product that would
greatly change the lives of people who
are poor because you could come into a
completely run-down building and through
augmented reality have your big screen
TV that you didn't pay for have
beautiful floors at least in your view
you could build entire cities with just
cue codes QR codes on the walls
amusement parks that are just entirely
generated by QR codes and it would cost
nothing I'm picturing like somebody
they're walking in their in their
augmented apartment with these beautiful
like floors and then they get like a
sliver and it just completely breaks the
immersion oh see I was thinking they
would run into someone who also thinks
they live there and that they're in a
relationship but like you're not
interact with them because in your
reality you don't know that person in
their reality you're like their their
wife or whatever
weird imagine Perma filter but that's
what I mean like you'd be asking
everyone to live in their own augmented
reality and so we would have no
connection to each other and so you'd
have no idea how you already kind of do
that when you think about like your
phone when you look at when you think of
your phone and where you get your
information you kind of are living in a
different reality from somebody that
gets their information from somewhere
else so how far off is it really let's
read this one Raymond g Stanley Jr says
Hannah Claire you don't have to worry
about watching Fast and Furious 10. it's
definitely the worst of them all what
say you the panel no no
Raymond you are wrong my friend I'm
sorry uh Tim will disagree with me nine
no but I'm just saying nine is by far
the least impressive of the Fast and the
Furious yes that's the one where they go
to outer space I get it but the the
summer the self-referential humor in
that one is bad he is wrong 10 is 10 is
fine
I'm living in suspense like I can't
fulfill this wager because I can't come
up with opinions on these things like
that would kill this debate they had an
opportunity to give Dom superpowers I am
not joking okay they already have Idris
Elba and the fast Universe who's a
cybernetic super soldier okay
so when they went to space I'm telling
you what should have happened was there
should have been a technologically
advanced like super reactor in a car and
they're doing like an experiment Dom's
driving it and then Ludacris is like hit
the warp drive and then he hits it and
then he's like it's not working it's
malfunction he's like a board hits the
abort but then electrical charge just
I'm telling this big wave hits the whole
crew and they all get super power the
reason the reason the movies still work
is because as ridiculous as every single
one of them is
Vin Diesel plays it completely straight
and that's why you can still buy into it
because as much as ludicrous you could
have done that like could have done that
with superpowers yes and it would still
be about family every time as long as
it's about family he comes up with
another way to justify this movie series
hear me out Transformers fast crossover
oh it writes itself that is a genius
idea I couldn't see that happening also
driving bumblebee dude
they've already they're doing Hasbro
Cinematic Universe with GI Joe and the
Rock already played in one of the GI Joe
movies so you can automatically cross
them over right there yes because we
need more cinematics yes coming back for
fast uh yep 47. yeah the like and
they're still they're supposedly still
going to make the the female one the
female rock they're no they're making a
female Fast and the Furious I'm down I
don't care like
dude but they gotta get okay maybe not
superpowers but it would be cool if like
the rock like in the beginning of the
movie he gets like okay so they already
have Idris Elba a terrorist gets like a
microwave Cannon a new experimental
energy weapon and he fires it and Dom
like pushes the rock out of the way but
the Rock's arm gets blasted ah and it
just vaporizes he becomes Jacks for
Mortal Kombat
one big like massive cyber arm yeah
that's like he's he punches the ground
and launches him in the air dude come on
he's just Will Smith from the robot
movie if you get one or he needs two
arms then it needs to be Jax I do feel
like any movie is better when people
have super powers
of space it made sense Multiverse
Raymond g Stanley is wrong
it's fantastic it's just this he's he's
wrong I'm sorry Multiverse dude I don't
know man it's a Hot Topic how long have
these movies been around during this
concert
2001. first son came out in 2001 so
we're over the 20-year mark now
Omega rasetsu says I am black but
identified with dirty claw Logan
Wolverine as a kid in the early 80s I
gave less than a rat's ass that
Wolverine was white or that he was
really short like that
you Jackman who is like super tall like
yeah they just can't do the the
character Justice they get ahead Tom
Cruise do it and he should have a
Canadian accent let's be honest static
shock was my favorite superhero when I
was a kid I thought the show was
fantastic I thought I I just like the
way they did for those aren't familiar
it's uh Virgil Hawkins I believe his
name is he's he's got electric powers
the story they did in the cartoon is
that he's he's being forced to pressure
to join a gang there's a gang fight at
the Docks he's given a gun he throws him
to the water he doesn't want to do it
and then when the police come and fire
tear gas it causes an explosion which
leaks is experimental chemical over all
these gangbangers and now you've got one
kid who didn't want to be there who gets
super powers and a whole bunch of gang
bangers who have superpowers and many of
them become criminals I just thought
that was like a cool kind concept that's
an actual Marvel thing isn't it DC DC
yeah because I have well it wasn't
originally but DC Warner Brothers got
the rights and now it's basically now
now it is DC I'm pretty sure yeah okay
because I remember a comic book of
static shock yes that's just what I know
they did a static movie yeah I always
hated it when they adapted like books
the the modern static Comics are bad
that bums me out man I think a static
movie could be would be so cool
that was important to you to these
people and it was it was very social
justice yeah it was there the the
cartoon was absolutely was it enough for
today's day and age honestly probably
yeah it's like have you seen like yeah I
think it'll be bad like people would be
mad about it no no no no no I don't it
was more deftly handled it's like it's
like Captain Planet Captain Planet is
like the Super Ultra Mega you see they
used to do activisty stuff in media but
it was a light touch like you everything
planet was not a light no no that's what
I'm saying that's the that's the high
bar example of like the worst like the
worst back then like you you have what I
like about static is it does talk about
issues you have one of the gang bangers
he goes to jail he gets college at
superpowers and then he and then he
reforms and becomes a hero like these
are cool Concepts that address a lot of
these issues turns out his best friend's
gay and they make an issue about his dad
being racist or something and I'm like I
thought it was totally fine yeah
whenever it wasn't over the top it
wasn't Green Arrow I used to do plenty
of this stuff as well
so much even like you look at everything
back then and they subtly put stuff in
like Fresh Prince of Bel-Air touched on
a lot of social issues I still loved
watching it as a kid they did it in a
way that was more authentic actually
honest it wasn't too forced yeah now
it's forced and it's not about it's not
about what helps us live together it's
about what's divisive so it used to be
like hey man you know don't be racist
right let's let's just try to get along
and it's like I can certainly understand
that equal rights under the law now it's
like enforce it is the woke cult stuff
there's a big difference between
constitutional rights and a
constitutional republic and woke cult
indoctrination I like the Constitutional
classical liberal indoctrination I don't
like the welcome doctrination that's
easy way to put it yeah
yeah
all right Miguel Rivera says Tim xqc
needs to be shouted out he just signed
with kick moving people away from twitch
and their garbage censorship big deal
for culture War do you know you know
about that I read about that earlier
today there's a lot of people that are
talking about moving to kick that's
becoming a big thing also because twitch
now twitch gave the 70 30 split to
people but it's like impossible
standards to meet if you actually uh for
profits like if you actually want it
like the the requirements to do that
limit it down to like only the top of
the top creators which is not really all
that fair so it's a very interesting
space to see how all that stuff is
playing out because there is a real time
like if you saw the thing the other day
Andrew Tate did a 432
000 concurrent live stream on Rumble
really Andrew Tate did 432 000
concurrence on Rumble the other day and
like and he the first thing he called
out when they talked about because they
they talked about what was going on in
prison they talked about all that stuff
but he said he the first thing he called
out he called out YouTube for their
censorship and all this stuff and said
you no longer control the culture you no
longer control access to information the
way you once did and a lot of those
platforms are the ones where more and
more of these battles are being fought
because these companies are pricing out
creators people with large platforms
that are not inherently political you
know a lot of these creators are going
over to rumble and only the ones that
are not afraid of being called names the
ones that are willing to do it because
they're like oh you're going to rumble
that's an ALT right Yahtzee platform why
would you do that yeah
um I don't know I don't know who owns it
but this deal is massive it's like 100
million over two years and that puts
them into like top 10 for all athletes
ever for contracts it's an insane number
A lot of people are comparing this to
when Microsoft launched mixer but that
was pretty woke and had all these rules
and stuff cake is definitely more
friendly you can get away with a lot on
the platform in terms of content and
there's been a lot of propaganda against
them a ton of Articles being written to
try and dissuade you from using kids
look at all the they're not moderating
they're not stopping anything from
coming out here your kid is gonna turn
into some type of tiki torch wearing
like well amazing person if you let them
on this platform Wikipedia says it's uh
its focus is looser moderation and
higher Revenue share there you go but
the the articles are being accused of
being an alt-right group soon absolutely
yeah like really a matter of time but
yeah it's a it's a huge deal a lot of
people I did see some they're like
they're giving them 100 million dollars
for this one guy when they should be
spreading that money over hundreds or
dozens of mid-sized creators I was like
that's an interesting there's a fair
argument it is one of the more recent
attempts to Dethrone twitch is the de
facto streaming King and twitch is
terrible yeah they're they're so bad I I
just don't like them well it's resulted
in PR which is good I mean we're talking
about it so obviously there's some value
in that yeah absolutely that's wild the
biggest deal of all time he's streaming
right now well good twitch is bad
twitch is very bad
wait you don't like hot tub streams what
are you telling me
Andrew Roland says in Man of Steel
Krypton had artificial births and
Superman was the first natural birth in
100 years Zod called this natural birth
heresy
I liked Man of Steel do you like Man of
Steel I thought it was great uh I mean
it's like it's uh I understand the
complaints about it in in accuracy to
Superman lore in the comics and they do
seem to have an aversion to wanting to
tell classic Superman stories also there
is a cameo in the flash which I'm not
going to give away that I was probably
going it's already publicly known I know
but I I just I don't know who's not
everyone in this room I don't know I
necessarily for the people
necessarily want to ruin it for them but
it's been very controversial to a lot of
people because of the technology that we
used to do it
um zod's appearance was good in the
movie yes so I really really like that
it was really funny listening to Michael
Shannon try to to figure out how he was
alive in the movie when they did the
interview they're like he's like yeah
they called me they want me to be in the
movie I'm like aren't I isn't my
character dead they're like oh it's the
Multiverse it's like I don't really know
what that means but sure there are no
rules he explained he goes it's kind of
now like it's kind of like a bunch of
CEOs worth billions of dollars playing
with action figures he's like and then
Dodge shows up here and this person
shows up here and they're battling and
that's what it feels like I feel like
you dying in a in a superhero movie
actually increases your likelihood of
being in the next movie it's worse
they'll just let you go but if you die
there was actually Stakes there which
means that it means it's something to
bring you back all right Jay Money 95
says Doctor disrespect called Hassan a
fat phony on his stream today for
talking about him boycotting Call of
Duty he also laughed about it saying
Hassan wouldn't dare talk the same way
to him in person I I think
I don't know if Hassan's a phony other
than he's just not a very in-depth guy
like he's a very surface level guy so
his views of things are just going to be
very much like
on the surface this thing happens it
seems to be anti-lgbtq he's opposed to
it Dr disrespect is probably more so
just a gamer but when something happens
sees what's going on gives his thoughts
on it
so you know I can understand why he's
calling him a phony yeah but I don't
think uh I don't think Hassan's opinions
are genuine
for the most part because there was one
video he did where he was talking about
me and he criticized the military
industrial complex but then praised the
war in Ukraine like that's a paradox I
just don't think he's intelligent
it's one way to put it
you know it seemed weird like one like I
was reading stuff the other day and I'm
like I'm watching it's like Garth Brooks
fights with people over Bud Light and
Nick Merks talking about Call of Duty
I'm like did I really expect on my end
of the world bingo card I didn't expect
any of this stuff to be the things that
we as a community as a culture would be
fighting about these days it's
ridiculous
I thought it would be a meteor but it's
Garth Brooks it's Garth Brooks in Kid
Rock
shows in drag shows in Call of Duty it's
ridiculous
Shannon says Bank your vote as the
Republicans early voting for 2024 vote
early if you can not just on Election
Day absolutely
and we need Republicans to be uh helping
with mail-in voting and knocking on
doors and in cities absolutely in cities
remember when
um in like the early 2000s when the
Democrats had rocked the vote and and
Republicans had like redeemed the vote
and it was like a religious a religious
one you could already see I've never
heard of it you could have already you
could already see the culture shifting
at that point they just they didn't have
the ability to catch the youth they just
couldn't or come up with good messaging
yeah
crack comedy says you want to hire
people to do what they already do hire
me to host a cultural show where I
travel across the USA going to Comedy up
in mics visit Oddities American
Battlefield Battlefield Fields most
importantly talk to average people
agreed I wrote down your name I'll take
a look
and we're actually thinking about if we
could do some more men in the street
stuff find a host who could specifically
go and talk to regular people just ask
them general questions I will go anytime
yeah I'll talk to everyone we'll go to
like DC and go to Freedom Plaza and be
like what are your thoughts like you
know have at it because we were planning
on doing something like this a long time
ago we never did so you know man on the
street stuff is the best in my opinion
what's your body count no other
questions that they asked him the best
question yeah what do you rate this no
it's really funny because um John Boy
media which is like a baseball like they
used to just do baseball commentary it
started out as a YouTube channel which
has grown into like a very very large
Media Company because it got very big
now they've started to do stuff like
that and you like the first they
expanded into other sports and all this
other content and they're great as far
as how they actually Market their social
media is great now that you see them
doing these mana on the street type
things and everybody in the comments
like please no not bar stool don't
become bars anything but that I think
well done man on Street stuff is the
best way to take like the sociological
thermometer of our country right like
you can really see some interesting
psychological and sociology sociological
developments at work you just have to
have the people willing to talk to a lot
of people do it it takes man hours and
there's a lot of curation there so it's
like you'll get a feeling after watching
some of those that you at the end of
society that Civilization is falling
because you'll hear all of these stupid
comments but then you have to remember
that they talk to 50 or 100 people that
day and you're hearing them share with
you the five people that said the
absolute stupidest thing that they had
so we did man on the street stuff for my
doc that uh I was telling you guys about
the cancel doctor and uh it's number one
very it was surprisingly way more
difficult to get people to talk to us uh
than we thought unless we did it in a
place where people were drunk and then
you just got a lot of craziness wow
um but it is true that you know you do
have to luckily I was surprised even in
LA and how many down the road in the
middle kind of responses you got that
wouldn't work for a documentary exactly
it's a lot it's a lot of not lie by
structure but it's heavily crafting
narrative depending on what your topic
is because you're gonna get in fact I
would almost like more and I know it
wouldn't be successful if you want to
white pill a bunch of people share with
them the ridiculously middle of the road
responses like look you are not alone a
lot of the country is full of perfectly
rational people it's just not that
interesting to anyone but people in the
culture War who are sick of the things
that go either end of the spectrum
Brett's documentary you are here and
it's all right it's just all regular I'm
down for that let's go Jeff Bader with a
very big Super Chat says Tim is Right
human life is a federal issue I I do
believe so I believe the Constitution is
a human rights IT addresses our human
rights within this nation and um I think
you need structure at the state level
I'm happy to debate it that's what I
like about this year you switched me on
that one so kudos to you oh I mean I
don't know but I guess what I'm saying
now is it kind of feels like it was
better before they overturned it meaning
the federal issue was mostly restricted
at a certain point now the issue it
seems like
now they're just blanket allowing so
I'll ask you this is it better if
federally abortion is banned after 16
weeks or if half the state's ban it
completely in half allow abortion to
nine months
yeah I mean it's even even beyond that I
mean the argument that changed me was it
doesn't even matter uh what the end
result is it just comes down to a
constitutional right and it's
fundamentally a constitutional right and
a right to life I think Congress needs
to you can't have Federal legislation I
think Congress is vocal I think you need
I'm not against Federal Regulation I
just think what we saw when we over to
Monroe v Wade was that all of the states
suddenly were like well what what are
our stances on this we got to go back to
the 1800s look at our laws I think you
have to have it hammered out at the
state level I'm happy for a Federal
Regulation if it really is the best way
to ensure constitutional rights I just
think ultimately if you don't have
structure and order at a smaller level
it all falls apart
yeah I I the states do have different
laws on gun issues too so it's it's
entirely possible right that is another
argument that's like but yeah but when
it comes to the interpretation the one
thing you said that really hit me was we
can't have States having you know
debating on a state level what
personhood is right what a human life is
I mean that's beyond have they been
doing that with governments with in
relation to like the 3D printed weapon
debate no no but there's no question of
life yeah right with abortion there's a
question of when life begins I mean I
don't think there's a question I think
they'll left it just lying yeah I think
so
all right
let's grab what do we got
Rudy casone says I don't think
Republicans lost the Senate and
underperformed with Congress over
abortion I believed him had it right one
word harvesting yeah
yeah yeah
all right grizzlok says today you could
make Captain Planet a movie starring
Greta tunberg with a musk Trump analog
as the villain and you'd still get in
trouble for not making the cafe trans
women of color do they do anything with
Captain Planet does he get movies I know
I have not seen anything I like having a
planet you know I don't like about cabin
Planet they never use their rings have
you noticed that yeah don't they don't
they use heart they heart very rarely do
they ever actually use their rings and
they almost only ever summon Captain
Planet and I'm like dude you can you can
shoot fire out of that ring did you see
the live-action remake where Captain
Planet is like a butcher was it Don
Cheadle or yes it's amazing I like um
uh greasy Tales version on YouTube I
haven't seen it he's uh fat and it's
because he eats birds but the birds eat
plastic and the plastic can't be
digested
yeah that one's really good and he's
like what have you done the bear all
right everybody if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends become a member at
timcast.com and support our work you can
follow the show at timcast IRL you can
follow me personally everywhere at
timcast Elon you want to shout anything
out just uh if people want to go check
out my company the film's on there at
guardwatches.com we're wearing them yes
sir amazing EG ardwatches.com thank you
for wearing it yeah super cool
it's crazy you can see the springs in
the front of it yeah the Dual balance
wheels on that one that's our most
popular watch that's the Qantas and we
have those amazing uh those amazing ads
I think it's just good for people to
watch you should just go to your site
and watch your videos that I tell people
go to the set and watch the videos it's
our biggest if you see a watch there you
want to buy it you happen to buy it you
happen to come across a watch on a watch
website if it speaks to you
if your credit card falls on the table
and accidentally types itself into the
way came for the came for the video
stayed for the watches and this thing
it's got like a what's it called rotor
yeah it's an automatic watch yeah with a
dual balance wheelie it's got a thing is
when you walk around it spins winding it
up that's great asymmetrical curved
sapphire crystal it's worth going to the
website just to see the shape of the
sapper super cool that's really cool
yeah cool well when you're done watching
these videos I think you should follow
at timcast news on Twitter and Instagram
it's the best we have some really
interesting content coming up uh from
all of our journalists I think you'll
like it uh you can follow me personally
on Instagram at hannahclared.b and on
Twitter at hcbroml thanks so much it's
been great have a great weekend
guys if you'd like to follow me you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
Brett dasovic on both of those platforms
pop culture crisis is Live on YouTube 3
P.M Eastern Standard Time that is noon
Pacific you should join us there it's a
lot of fun and you guys can follow me at
Kellen PDL it was a good show tonight uh
looking forward to the weekend and may
God Save the Queen man
all right everybody thanks for hanging
out and we'll we'll be back up with
Clips throughout the weekend and then
back live on Monday